e
what you got I just I can't get through
to her so I have a bill down in Senate
education and they're still like over an
okay the time being 10 10 we'll get
started here with our public hearings uh
before I start I just want to embarrass
my daughter Joelle Joel stand up she's
uh here to see how things work at the
state house or don't
work okay now I'll um we'll start with
we uh Senator Lang will uh introduce the
Bill thank you very much Mr chair thank
you members of the committee it's I'm
glad to be back in house Ways and Means
my first committee when I served in the
House Representatives was here in the
house uh on ways and means so 4:32 uh an
old topic up for with the new bill um
Advanced deposit wagering this is
basically betting on horses um the
ability to do you know go bed on the
Kentucky Derby uh online um this bill
has a different wrinkle to it while it's
unclear at the Attorney General's office
whether this was legal or not legal and
the bill was originally brought forward
the request to lottery in the Attorney
General's office um last year and we ran
into some headaches and so we re
rejiggered it and made it look different
and brought it back um this bill uh
establishes that that uh process would
be legal um require that people get
licensed to be able to provide those
Services those licensed entities would
would pay um a tax on the handle um that
tax would go to Lottery um in the in the
new Wrinkle in this bill um in keeping
with the theme that I've heard from this
committee on over and over again
charitable gaming is about charitable
gaming it's about Charities so what this
bill seeks to do is without trying to uh
create a huge amount of workload for the
lottery division where the bill would
take the revenue which is estimated a
little over $200 million a year uh 200
sorry $200,000 a year2 200 million
dollar we talking about a different
thing um but 200 million $200,000 a year
um allow Lottery to pick a a third party
intermediary non for-profit to be able
to manage that that money and issue
grants to Charities within the state who
don't currently participate in
charitable gaming um for whatever reason
whether they're on weit lists or whether
they just never applied for it before
would have allowed so in in the vision
is that we would have somebody like the
center for nonprofits that knows
Charities across the entire state to
administer this program receive Grant
requests and then issue the grants out
and complete a report back to the uh
Lottery to to show how all the money was
spent what charities got the money what
the purpose of the money was that's the
Bild of a nutshell happy to take
questions thank
you do we have questions yes
representative ducet
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
question you you referenced uh it was
Senate Bill
190 I don't remember the number from
last year okay came out of this
committee uh
itl uh I think it was 154 voice voted on
the floor and you said you jiggered this
one the jiggering I see is you've
changed it from the monies going to
instead of the education trust fund it's
to some extra party for distribution for
Charities what else has changed in
anything just tax rate is different as
well okay the tax rate is in alignment
with so again under re I'm going to use
the word retail although I don't know if
that's the right word Charlie you'll
correct me if I'm wrong but but the OTB
we currently have now off track betting
that we currently have now you can go to
the brook and place a bet on a horse
race has a tax rate this put the tax
rate for this and the tax rate for that
in alignment so in in the old bill that
was not true the tax rate was tax rates
were different so this puts the bill in
alignment with current tax rate that are
charg for the OTP or the off track
betting on horses that we do now at the
brook follow up follow up so the current
tax rate is dictated by RSA 284 and
there's only one entity in the state
that's licensed and maybe I can ask
Lottery about this one entity which is
the brook that can take simulcast
wagering legally in New Hampshire right
now that is my understanding although I
think they're two eligible only one
actually has one okay I've I've
heard I've heard uh many an argument
about this being a gray area with the
interstate racing act or whatever um my
contention is and my understanding of
the law at least New Hampshire state law
law is you have to uh hold a license and
and I think the federal statute I did
some notes and some
research and let me State this the
interstate horse racing act deems a
wager on horse horse racing across state
lines is legal provided the wager and
the method of the wager is legal in the
same state where the better is in the
state where the actually where the race
actually takes place so in the federal
stat statute it talks about it being
legal in the state that it's taken in
order to be legal in the state of New
Hampshire you have to have a license
under RSA 284 so th
this in in my humble opinion is
something that needs to be addressed
that's the intent of the bill is to
address it is to make it legal and make
a license requirement make sure it's
clear that you have that you have to get
a license to provide the service in the
state of New Hampshire and and pay tax
follow thank you Mr chairman and as I've
contended in many of these
hearings the state has owed Revenue
rather large Revenue in my estimation
and it needs to be pursued so I'm I'm
totally against this bill until such a
Time the state pursues what the states
respect Mr chair if I can again
understand the whole point of the bill
is to be absolutely clear to give
businesses that want to do the work do
do this function an ability to do the
function I understand that there may be
past practice that is is not either is
not clear has not been enforced but that
doesn't mean that we shouldn't look
forward and whether or not we want to
allow our citizens to do this function
and whether we want businesses to offer
this function in the state of New
Hampshire this bill is a forward-looking
bill not a backwards looking Bill I'm
looking going forward what we want what
we want to do and make absolutely clear
so there is no question because
apparently there is in somebody's mind
and it may not be mine may not be yours
but there is in somebody's to make it
absolutely crystal clear that this
functions allowed that the uh activity
is allowed that we encourage businesses
to come into the state to provide this
pay the tax and we're going to use that
tax to benefit the charities in the
state of New Hampshire follow up follow
up okay
so by that logic and let's speak logic
somebody's been taking these bets for
decades continues to take these bets
others are not taking these bets right
now and is pushing very hard to pay a
tax to pay 1.5% out of the revenue
gathering for what
purpose does that make sense to want to
take a a percentage out of your profit
line because it's a gray
area it doesn't make sense something's
not right here and what I believe is not
right is the fact that this should be
litigated this should be looked into and
this should be pursued because it's been
an illegal activity for decades under
RSA
284 and the state is owed its end and
moreover uh brick and morar places like
the old Rockingham Park I'm from Salem
lost Revenue the Brooke right now loses
Revenue the only operator who is legally
licensed to take this kind of
betting and if if I was you know taking
these types of online
bets I'd probably not be too concerned
with pursuing legislation that's going
to take money out of my pocket unless
there was an issue with it so I think it
needs to be looked at further and we
need to go forward with it after it gets
looked at so again this is not a
retrospective law we're not allowed to
make retrospective laws by our
constitution we can't make a bill a law
that looks back and forces activity
based on prior actions we can only make
bills laws based on today going forward
and that's what this bill seeks to do
today going forward whether or not this
committee thinks that advanced deposit
wagering betting on on the on the
Kentucky Derby uh should be legal in New
Hampshire and if we on your phone or or
through an advanced deposit wagering
process um should that be legal that's
the question past practice you can take
up the Attorney General's office and see
if they want to pursue an investigation
they want to pursue the Dr or Lottery
whether they want to pursue prior taxes
that doesn't mitigate or or or uh do
away with the reason for this bill which
is to make it going forward legal and to
allow Revenue again to go to our
Charities um to support our citizens
here in New
Hampshire representative
Southworth thank you for taking my
question could you say a little bit more
about how the money is going to get to
Charities cuz that's different sure so
I'll give you the perception the the
what what I what I the envisionment is
it's in and in the bill so again the the
lottery would find a third party
administrator take an RFP do an RFP for
it I'm thinking someone like the center
for nonprofits could take that could put
in for the RFP and manage the grant it's
basically that's what we're doing is
we're chating we're creating a
charitable fund grant for at the state
level and allow the um that uh
administrative agency the administrative
third party uh administrator to um issue
the grants and then when they issue
those grants so again the Northfield
Little League says we need new uniforms
we're going to put a grant in for 7500
bucks they would review the grant see
whether or not it fits the criteria so
again one of the criteria for a charity
to be eligible for Grants is that they
don't currently participate in
charitable gaming right we're not
looking for people to double dip we're
looking for reaching out into other
areas of our state other Charities
within our state and give them an
opportunity for the grants that they
need so the Little League doesn't
participate in charitable gaming and
they uh in the state of New Hampshire
and the and they would issue the Grant
and then they would report on an annual
basis the center for nonprofits here's
what we did with all your money the
$200,000 you gave us for a grant here's
how we gave those grants
out follow up follow up um I you know I
think the grant approach uh is
interesting um it is a change from some
things that have happened in the past my
um followup is right now a commission is
studying all this and one of the issues
is how Charities get money and how it is
fair and so on and so forth I'm just
wondering should we pass this before the
commission has um done a report on what
they recommend so while I do serve on
that commission um and we are looking at
the way charitable gaming operators
select their Charities we're not looking
at about and I and maybe I don't want to
misspeak because we're not at conclusion
so it's again I'm I'm doing it based on
what my perception of the Revol of it is
is that we're not necessarily looking at
how we get money to Charities who aren't
participating in charitable gaming it's
how it's only for oper operators and how
operators manage Charities within the
gaming operation uh uh gaming facility
so this would still reach out beyond
that mod okay thank you for clarifying
that uh
representative
PL thank you m thank you Mr chair thank
you for taking my question if we would
have passed this bill uh representative
set was talking about past history would
this would this uh color that past
history and and make uh make a case uh
for the person The Entity who was
violating all those years say well it's
legal now and it's one of the half
percent so we backcast a one and a half
percent instead of some other number so
I would I guess and I don't mean to
argue but I would make a statement that
it would be just the opposite that by
passing the bill that gives the Attorney
General a clear line say that prior to
this it was an illegal activity and you
are due the money but again I don't know
how you get money from someone who's
done illegal activity but um other than
bring a criminal charge against them
they would have to do something like
that so again I think that this is not a
retrospective law they could easily
Lottery could easily talk about you know
their your experience of any lensey
within the state of New Hampshire and
whether or not they've been violating
this law or not as a as a um you know as
a item under license requirements
representative fellows thank you Mr
chair good morning um I have a question
about the part that says um hire an
administrator to determine how to
distribute that money that comes in and
the estimate that we have is about
200,000 a year that would come in and
you described what that administrator
would do as receiving requests for grant
funding and reviewing that to me um it
seem I would I would
expect uh that
administrative uh person to cost at
least $50,000 which would be a year
which would be a quarter of the money
that's coming in and wouldn't it make
more sense to just let that money go
into the education trust fund and then
you'd have no loss for um that any sort
of administration to go with that sure
thank you for the question so um again
I'm trying to find it give me one second
um there's a cap on the revenue that the
third party administrator is allowed to
take and if I remember right it's 10%
I'm just trying to find it
um thank you page four um so there's a
cap so again the idea being that the
person who's doing this is already doing
grants and that this would just give
them a little more work and and have
that person that's already issuing so
the center for nonprofits is does do
things like check Grant distribution
from other Revenue sources and so again
I would say that there this would just
give them a little more Revenue to help
the alleviate the new administrative
overhead um but it's capped at 10% so
$21,000 based on the fiscal note would
be their maximum they're allowed to
request they could request less based on
how they administer and how efficient
they
are and to answer your last question so
the questions always keeps coming going
up in his committee is can we divert
gaming money to things other than
education right and so the answer is is
yes and I think you're going to get a
letter I I spoke about this prior from
the if you haven't gotten already from
the Attorney General's office um that
says that if if you remember in 1990 we
merged lottery in and we used to have
our own gaming commission and the money
was unrestricted we could do what we
want the legislature could do we want
Lottery money which is scratch tickets
and and and meab bucks and Mega Millions
and all of those games of of of Lottery
that Lottery is restricted so um it's
clear that we can divert this money
again and keeping in mind just like we
do at charitable gaming right the whole
point of the charitable gaming is the
Charities right uh people would say in
this committee and so um I'm trying to
keep with that intent of what games of
chance and charitable gaming were for
it's for Charities and to keep the money
in that realm representative spillsbury
thank you Mr chair Senator Lang I'm GNA
ask you a question of interpretation so
sure on on page three this provides uh
line 30 and
31 that uh charitable grants from
eligible contributions to charitable
organizations can go to those who are
not participating in charitable
gaming and then on page
four the last in the list of uh what the
charitable third party Financial
intermediary will be doing says in j
line 14 and 15 limit and condition
charitable grants so that they are
dispersed equitably throughout the state
now there's a vast Universe of Charities
that are under the first of those two
Provisions I cited not currently in
involved in charitable gaming how do you
envision that this
Authority uh in Little
J uh would be
interpreted so first equitably
throughout the state what does that
thank you for that so the intention was
to make sure that if we happen to hire
an or an administrative organization
that was from conquered that the only
people that ever got charitable grants
was from conquered um we wanted to make
sure that it was geographically
dispersed or dispersed throughout the
state so that line is is to give them
Direction and say that you need to look
Beyond just your own town that you're in
um we look at um so again we talk about
weight lists that are on there so a char
could choose not to do the weight list
and just apply for a grant and get off
the weit list the charity could because
they're not participating in charitable
gaming they they don't get dates because
they're on the waight list um so they
could choose to do that again the goal
was to make sure that uh a charity from
Pittsburgh New Hampshire has just as
much uh chance of getting uh a a a grant
from this organization as a charity from
Nashua so I just would point out that's
interesting I appreciate your
interpretation
and I see when it says
dispersed throughout the state you have
a
geographic uh Point here that eluded me
it uh representative
elberger thank you Mr chair thank you
senator for taking my question I'm a
little bit confused here I often find
myself this way uh when you look at the
fiscal
pages uh it points out that the lottery
fund education trust fund Lottery
revenues credit blah blah and it talks
about the revenue
projections from this it looks like the
revenue would be going to the education
trust fund instead it's being directed
and the the revenue here looks to me
like it's going to be a net gain for the
fund because the note talks about the
education trust fund either I don't have
the same note as you it's a chart it's a
chart oh you have you have the as
introduced version so there's a new
version ah sorry that's that's if you
look at the amended version and fiscal
note is different all right well then
let me follow up Mr chair follow up
thank you thank you um why are we not
giving the funds to the education trust
fund instead of to Charities sure thank
you for the question so again the idea
being is keeping in line that gaming in
New Hampshire's purpose has been we
we've made a legislative decision to
have gaming money revenues go to
Charities um with with with in games of
chance and this kind of horse racing um
unlike Lottery which we've made a
distinct constitutional provision to say
it must go to education so don't get me
wrong the legislature could choose to
send it to the education chest fund my
point is that this is in Theory new
Revenue um in keeping with new Revenue
in line with our past practices of
having charitable gaming be focused on
Charities uh it's been a a significant
Topic in this in this committee room as
well as mine on the other side of the
wall um that making sure the money stays
within Charities for that Lottery money
stay within in
yeah uh anybody else yes representative
Ames
uh first question is uh in response to a
question from representative Southworth
you um said that you thought that the
commission that's looking at uh the new
gaming laws that relate to charal gaming
um uh would um not be addressing the
subject that's in this bill
and as you know I too sit on that and I
you did qualify what you said saying
this isn't something that the commission
has yet reached but uh I would say that
I would think as one other member of
this commission that uh it's very likely
that there would be interest in this in
effect it's filling out the picture of
charal gaming um looking at uh
charitable entities that are not um
for whatever reason maybe they just
couldn't get a slot but participating in
charitable gaming and uh and providing
something for them so I maybe you could
respond a little further about why you
think this would be outside the perview
or interest of uh the commission well so
my it's it's not part of the five
charges that that commission has and
while we've expanded that and fairly
significantly uh in that commission what
we're looking at um again
we were looking at charitable gaming in
terms of games of chance uh HHR and
those things this is a new activity um
that that is not that doesn't currently
exist um as far as the advanced deposit
wagering piece so um so again I don't
know I'm trying to remember if we even
talked about it in the commission um but
again I think that again this bill
fulfills the mission of keeping gaming
and revenues from gaming and the
charitable and in charitable Market um
and they may be interested it and may
like the fact that in fact we are
reaching out beyond the uh the um
Charities that can only get slots that
we're we're looking for other
opportunities to be able to uh use
charitable gaming Monies to uh support
Hampshire follow it's really a further
question okay um and it um
it's really about the order of magnitude
of the money that's going to
be potentially funneled into
this um
new intermediary that would then send
the money out to Charities
um and
the what the picture I have in my mind
is that we're talking about to start
with any the only numbers we have here
are perhaps 200,000 or a little less
than that when you get through the
10% um and uh and then you
got I don't have no idea how many
Charities are out there but there are a
lot of Charities and you've got this uh
one criteria of dispersal um Geographic
that uh uh was mentioned in
another question um but how in the world
are you going to pick between all these
Charities other than giving a give a
dollar to each one of them or something
like that I mean uh uh you're giving a
lot of authority without any direction
from the
legislature to a private inter
intermediary um who's going to somehow
either uh go through a lottery system or
do something maybe more selective that's
totally selective and give all the money
to something that sounds good but what
how do you respond to that
I thank you for the question so again um
you got to start somewhere right so my
goal is again this is a 200 th roughly
after expenses a $200,000 grant that the
states issuing we regularly go through
processes for issuing grants we don't
give we don't equally disperse the money
when we issue grants in the state of New
Hampshire whether it's from the water
fund or whether it's from anything else
right people base their decisions on the
merits of of what the grant request is
and what I'd say is that the to use my
example the Little League of the the
little league in Northfield that asked
for $7500 it's told they only going to
get $5,000 I promise you they're still
going to be happy right they're still
going to very much appreciate the fact
that they got some assistance from the
organization okay um thank you
Senator sorry I don't mean to be rude
but I need to run back to Senate
education no problem at all okay next up
bragon thank you Mr chairman members of
the committee uh for the record Peter
bragon a senior policy advisor at predy
strategies uh here today uh representing
Church H Downs uh best known obviously
as the home of the Kentucky Derby
something that was mentioned earlier by
Senator Lang the longest continuously
run sporting event in America a week
from Saturday will be the 150th running
of the Kentucky Derby um Churchill DS is
a publicly traded Corporation with
Gaming facilities and tracks in over a
dozen states uh in 30 over 30 facilities
and we do uh have an app uh for advanced
deposit wagering um called twin spes uh
that is uh used
Nationwide um uh in New Hampshire I
guess I would uh direct your attention
to the uh last page of the bill as
amended by the Senate and the fiscal
note and really just the first two lines
of the fiscal note this bill seeks to
license and regulate Advanced deposit
wagering on horse racing and then in
parenthesis Advanced deposit wagering
currently takes place in New Hampshire
and is not subject to
regulation the interstate horse racing
Act of 1978 authorized electronic
betting on horse
races States could choose
to
uh license and tax those activities they
could choose to ban those activities
effectively or they could do nothing at
all um and in number of states a dozen
or so at least including New Hampshire
did nothing at all and so a number of
companies including Churchill Downs had
operated Advanced deposit wagering uh in
the states that uh did not do it because
was authorized by federal law and I
think that's the the key sticking point
with those who think there was something
illegal going on is that um a number of
companies ours included operating under
the assumption that it's allowed by
federal law unless the state does
something more restrictive so that's
kind of where we're at uh back in 2021
late 2021 early 2022 Churchill Downs uh
expressed interest in purchasing the
Chasers Poker Room in Salem and in its
discussions with the Lottery Commission
and the Attorney General um they
expressed their concern about this
so-called gray area um and obviously as
we all know I think the Lottery
Commission is pretty strict with respect
to its licensing of operators for
charitable gaming in New Hampshire and
it was clear to Churchill that being
involved with Advanced deposit wagering
New Hampshire uh would be in a gray area
uh may not uh uh look good uh in terms
of being a operator of charal gaming in
Hampshire so we voluntarily stopped
doing the advanced deposit wagering and
pledged to work with the Lottery
Commission to put together some kind of
uh to support a bill that would
establish once and for all clearly in
state law whether it's legal or not I
guess I would say to you uh you should
make a decision is it illegal or is it
legal and and pass a law to clarify that
I will say that if you pass pass a bill
like this that um authorizes it it's
effective I think the effective date on
this is July 1st of this year it only
applies this illegality only applies to
anything that happens after July 1st if
for some reason the Attorney General
determines that something illegal was
happening which we very much doubt uh
nothing prevents the Attorney General
from going back uh prior to July 1st
2024 um and taking action on that so I
think the Crux of the matter is um the
the because New Hampshire hadn't taken
any steps regarding Advanced deposit
wagering we were operating under the
federal law and I think that's how we
end up where we are now um right now we
basically have a an unlevel playing
field we have companies that have uh
been operating so back in 2022 almost
two years ago Churchill voluntarily
stopped Advanced deposit wagering in New
Hampshire uh other companies have
continue to do it for two years uh I
would uh
I would I would suggest that if the
Attorney General thought that this was
an illegal activity that they would have
issued a cease and desist order to those
that have continued to do it so
basically what's happening is our
competitors get to do it but we don't uh
and all we're asking is make it clear in
law uh and everybody's got a Level
Playing Field uh consumer protections
are involved and it would be better for
everybody and uh then finally I know
there's been some questions about the uh
the additions in the Senate regarding
the chable third party Financial
intermediary and whether it should go to
this charitable group to do something or
whether it should go to the education
trust fund if this committee decides
that they want to just go back to the
education trust fund would be happy to
work it's a relatively simple change to
the bill to to make that happen so happy
to work with the committee on that if
that's your pleasure so I think that's
the uh the main points I want to make is
uh we do not feel this is an illegal
activity uh we do feel that the
interstate the federal law governed this
because New Hampshire took no action now
some states took action and they
effectively made it difficult or
impossible to do Advanced deposit
wagering uh and so we don't operate in
those States in those states that do
license it then we operate in those
States uh as per their licensing and all
the other states like New Hampshire uh
we operate where the bets basically are
being accepted at a site in Oregon uh
which all the operators use and that's
kind of a Consolidated area for all the
activity so with that said I'd be happy
to answer any questions thank you
representative
ducet thank you Mr chair and thank you
for take my question I'm curious as to
uh if you can give me a date when twin
Spire started taking bets in New
Hampshire uh thank you for the question
uh representative I don't know that
although based on the discussions at the
hearing for Senate Bill 190 last year uh
you had suggested that was 2002 and um I
don't know any better than that I assume
you were informed on that so I'll I'll
go with that if that's what you think it
is I don't know follow up and you
stopped taking bets in
2021 probably
2022 22 okay
and what I'm hearing you testify to is
you believe this is legal but you stop
taking the bets because it's a gray
area uh the regulator of terrible gaming
New Hampshire felt it was a gray area
and uh if your regulator feels it a gray
area then probably pay attention to what
they say okay thank you
uh representative
shamber thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question representative
ducet brought this up earlier I believe
uh if this bill as presented becomes law
in New Hampshire how many other states
would it be acceptable in uh that would
accept these
Wagers um I don't know the exact
breakdown of states that specifically
authorize it states that say nothing and
states that prohibit it uh there's a
handful of states that I know prohibit
it um my recollection is there were a
dozen or so States maybe somewhere
between 12 and 20 probably that the law
is silent on it uh this law would only
apply to New
Hampshire representative Aly thank you
that leads into my question on I was
hearing that the federal law says that
you can only do this within the state
that um the racing is carried out in uh
but we've got other programs doing doing
this still in New Hampshire and nobody
how many of them are there can you tell
us who they are they aren't here are
they they're in Las Vegas and places
like that so I don't know exactly I know
there's three primary companies involved
in advanced deposit wagering one is
Churchill Downs not in New Hampshire
currently uh another is Express bets who
I believe has a lobbyist present here I
believe they're from Rhode Island uh and
a third one is called TVG I believe and
I'm not sure where they're located at
least one of those other ones is also a
publicly traded
company so they're still doing it in New
Hampshire though the federal law
apparently just doesn't allow them to do
it in New Hampshire well no I would say
that they are accepting bets from New
Hampshire residents uh and they believe
that under the federal law they're
allowed to do that and they are not
seeking to be licensed in New Hampshire
to operate charitable gaming so they you
know probably have less concern as to
what Lottery and attorney general may
think about the gray
area representative
ol um thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question I'm just trying to
understand the the logic of your
argument that this is a gray area or
it seems to me that the argument is the
federal government can tell the states
what to
state that seems to be the
argument New Hampshire doesn't have a
law regarding this but it does have
a anybody know how to take these new
things and put them on mute anybody
because they
don't do not
disturb oh yeah thank you um so besides
it's just someone trying to sell me
Medicare
that an interstate law interstate
commerce which requires action in the
state
for it to be legal under interstate
commerce but when there is no law in the
state it's not illegal because there is
no law but it's illegal in the state
because there is no
law I you see where I'm not really no
well neither do I so I I really don't
understand the argument
there uh don't understand my argument
yeah that it's legal yeah yeah I mean
our view is the um interstate commerce
uh Interstate horse racing act uh
allowed for electronic betting on horse
races and allowed states to uh regulate
uh Andor tax it and those states that
chose not to I see what you're saying
now uh those states that chose not to um
then uh it's something that's allowed by
federal
just a couple of questions uh the first
is on the
charitable part of this thing the the
new part um and you said you really
don't have a position on that one way or
the other um correct and I understand
that um I'm I'm wondering you you must
have participated in the Senate side
of the public side of this uh bill and
my question is
whether you uh whether you observed that
there were comments or information
provided about this part of the bill was
that testified too and can you share
that with us uh my recollection and it's
it's just that so there's a disclaimer
there my recollection that this
amendment regarding the charitable
charity issue uh was an amendment
brought forth at the executive session
and I don't believe it was part of the
original Bill uh and and I assume we
testified on the original bill um but
maybe not but I'm pretty sure the
amendment that made this the big change
was uh came in at executive session that
in accord with my impression um and then
uh if I may the other question is on the
order of magnitude of uh revenues and um
you we have in in this uh as amended
version uh a number
of uh
22,500 as I I guess the amount that's uh
would be
transferred um either to intermediaries
or we went back to the other route would
go to the education trust fund um and it
might be a slightly different number if
we did a different rate uh but whatever
um my question is whether you think
that's in the right range the
212,000 uh thank you for the question my
understanding is it probably is um I
know starting in 2019 2020 the Lottery
Commission was uh surveying the various
providers of advanced deposit wagering
uh I think uh initially in 2021 or so
they they tried to do some rule making
realized they didn't have the authority
to do the rulemaking but in advance of
that was collecting information from the
providers of advanced deposit wagering
uh and so Lottery I'm pretty sure has
access to
uh what the total wager uh is for New
Hampshire residents um I've been told
also compared it to some similar States
uh to see if was in the range so I think
it's based on a total wages of wagering
of $17 million and this would be 1.25%
of whatever that was yes I think it's
pretty close probably thank you okay
thank you um oh one uh representative
duet okay thank you Mr chairman thank
you for taking my question you you State
of the State didn't do anything relative
to Advanced deposit wagering it's just
brought to my attention and it's
actually written in this bill on page
three line 25 through 2 uh 25 and 26
talks about parool rule
525 which
specifically uh which is uh was enacted
by the racing commission here in New
Hampshire to allow for advanced deposit
wagering and in order to do so you
284 it seems yet again we have state
statute state
law that
dictates how
ADW happens in New Hampshire and the
gray area is getting darker is is my
comment on this uh thank you for the
question I'm I'm I'm aware of exactly
what that refers to um and I can
certainly look at that and I would say
again that uh regardless uh passing this
bill uh takes effect July 1st uh it does
not in any way uh erase whatever
happened prior to that and if the
Attorney General determines that there
is some illegality there they have the
ability to pursue that this does not
erase
that okay thank you for your testimony
thank
thank you Mr chair and members of the
committee thank you for this opportunity
to testify today on Senate Bill
432 uh I work with deur and prol here in
conquer and here today representing
express bet uh an ADW
provider and so what I want to do today
I think you are all pretty familiar with
the concept again this is sort of the
second goal round you saw this if very
very similar Bill last year um I again
like Mr bragon want to highlight that
first sentence of the fiscal note
because I think very simply this is what
this bill is all about um and it says
this bill seeks to license and regulate
Advanced deposit wagering on horse
raising Advanced deposit wagering
currently takes place in New Hampshire
is not subject to regulation so at the I
mean that's really what this is all
about it already takes place we operate
cury in the State uh you heard from
Churchill Downs obviously they they they
ceased operating we continue to operate
uh we disagree obviously that this is
illegal activity uh what I will say is
and I want to clarify about ADW we're
talking specifically about live horse
racing um and that's it nothing else
this doesn't go beyond that um it falls
into its own separate category so last
year you had a bill that would addressed
online gambling generally think you know
poker that's different uh this is
different than sports betting it's not
charitable gaming it's not HHR um so
this really is its own entirely separate
category and it's the only form of
gambling that currently takes place in
New Hampshire that isn't regulated and
that's really the purpose behind this
bill it licenses and regulates the
industry uh and with regulation
obviously comes the the revenue uh
whether to the state or in this case to
the the
Charities so I you know very simply at
the end of the day what this bill is all
about you have a you have gambling that
currently takes place in New Hampshire
that will likely continue regardless of
regardless of how you decide to vote on
this bill uh the question then with
respect to Senate Bill 432 is regulation
and revenue or status quo which is
neither so that's I mean that's really
the question before you today uh and
then just I want to address some of the
sort of the legal aspects or at least
some of the arguments that we've heard
today so in representative UL you had
asked about the federal law so what I'll
say about the federal law is that so the
federal law permits um this activity but
it doesn't preempt the states so the
states then can restrict it further and
many states have chosen to do so they
can either regulate and license the
activity which many states do uh they
can prohibit the activity or that third
sort of category of states which is
where New Hampshire currently Falls uh
is they just remain silent and don't
address it at all and that's sort of the
gray area that you've heard about today
but those sort of how the states address
this issue falling into one of those
three buckets that's really
wellestablished and I'm not aware of any
examples um where courts have decided
that states that are silent with respect
to this issue or that this activity is
illegal in states that have chosen to
remain silent with respect to this issue
uh also in New Hampshire
uh
specifically the legality here was
investigated by the AG's office back in
2022 the result of that investigation
was this legislation um so you have this
legislation was really based on the AG's
office's recommendation it was drafted
and is supported by lottery I think
that's all very important um I will also
say you know when we were discussing
this bill last year I had had
conversations with Lottery and asked
them is this something we can just deal
with in rules and the answer to that
question was no because they believe
they without this bill they have no
authority to regulate ADW so again the
fact that they have no current authority
to regulate ADW I think speaks to the
legality of ADW in the
state um and
then I I think the argument the idea
that express bet or the other providers
May owe taxes going back number of years
and yes we've operated for a number of
years um anticipating I'm sure
representative duett's question I don't
know exactly when Express bets started
operating but I can tell you we formed
in 2002 and if it wasn't 2002 it was
probably shortly thereafter so yes it's
been many of
years
um but this so what's so the only tax
rate that currently exists in the state
is the tax rate with respect to simoc
cast you know so that's that's what is
going on currently at the brook
they do simal cast that's an off off
trck betting facility um that's the one
location that currently offers simoc
cast and I want to go back then
to which this the line that
representative du said already called
out on page three lines 25 and
26 so this this exception which was
added this year is an exception
specifically for the simoc cast
providers in this state so the brook the
other um facility that could if they
wanted to offer simulcast but don't
currently is Belmont um this exempts
them from these licensing Provisions it
says you're already licensed for simoc
cast purposes we're going to spare you
this additional process but the fact
that that exists and it calls that out
and exempts them uh is all the more
reason why simal cast and ADW are two
separate
things and then you know I so with that
all being
said really I don't think any no there's
no legal basis again this was already
investigated by the AG's office and then
on top of that I would add and this is
hypothetically right again we don't
think there's really any legal basis or
what we're doing is illegal
hypothetically if there were a case if
the AG's office decided we did want to
bring a case I want to turn your
attention back to the fiscal note this
is
$212 is the estimate per year and that's
across multiple providers so let's say
there was a case and and the AG's office
sought it even 10 years back we're
talking about $2 million again that's
across multiple providers that's an
expensive case to try uh and they likely
wouldn't recoup the cost of that case so
another reason why it's unlikely that a
case will be pursued in New
Hampshire and on top of that I guess
what I'll say is if this bill were to
pass that doesn't preclude the AG's
office from still filing a lawsuit
so if the concern is revenue loss
Revenue then you would want to pass this
bill immediately because then the
revenue starts coming in coming in
immediately and I think the the fact
that the legislature now has seen this
bill last year and this year if it
weren't to pass again I think that makes
a potential case even more difficult
because the legislature has seen it
twice they knew about it and chose to do
nothing so I think that potentially
hurts the case as well
um so I guess in summary I mean if you
think the industry should be regulated
if you think the state is missing out on
Revenue then this bill makes all the
sense in the world and and we request
your support the alternative obviously
is the status quo which is no regulation
and no
Revenue happy to take any
questions representative
ducet thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question um Mr Thomas you
just testified that you spoke to Lottery
and they told you they have no authority
to regulate ADW can you tell me who told
you that at Lottery uh I had had a
conversation with um I believe it was
you and so I again to your
point I think the concern here is that
there's an there's an issue with
legality there's nothing that we're
aware of we're not aware of anything
issue because we've never heard from
anybody whether at lottery or the AG's
office that we should cease operating
obviously Churchill ceased operating I
think you heard from them today that
really it sounds like was a business
decision based on their charitable
gaming facility here in New Hampshire we
obviously don't have a charitable gaming
facility and we're not of any we're not
aware of any issue with legality outside
of the conversations within this
committee this is a bill that wasn't
opposed in the Senate and I don't think
you'll hear any testimony and opposition
today either
follow up follow up so express bet is
taking who you represent is taking bets
at present
correct and if this legislation was to
pass express bet would be paying 1.5% on
the bets taken 1.25% I'm sorry
1.25% on the bets taken why is it
express bet is here pushing this
legislation to take Revenue out of their
their own Pockets yeah because if it's
legal it's legal you're taking bets now
right why you sitting in front of us
yeah I mean that's a good question so I
say two things one um there's obviously
a consumer protection aspect here which
I think you know there are Bad actors in
the space so with respect to Consumer
Protection this is a good thing two it
just makes sense for us we are already
licensed um we operate in 38 States um
that
includes probably I think there's about
28 where we actively where we have an
actual licens and are regulated there's
about 10 um which are similar to New
Hampshire that are silent on the law we
still operate and obviously we're licens
and regulated in other states and follow
those rules um and just I would say take
pride in sort of being a safe and secure
platform uh the fact and and being
licensed and regulated wherever possible
and so this was a bill again uh you
heard about the investigation back in
2022 this bill was the result of that
investigation uh and we're just we think
it makes more sense to sort of work with
the state and work with Lottery than
than than fight this issue because we
are licensed and regulated in other
states representative
Aly thank you um I'm trying to figure
out the
relationship what um the rule making
section does on you say
that
you're do you have any physical do they
have any Express bets in TV BG or
whatever the name of that is and do they
have a physical presence in New
Hampshire no I'm not aware of any
physical presence so they're just on
taking bets across the internet correct
correct yeah and um but it looks like
you said that church showns did buy that
poker room in Salem so they have a
physical presence um under Ru making it
includes cludes it it is amending in the
ru making section not here but it says
the sale of paramutual pool pools is
authorized under
2222a 22b and
22d which is the new Advanced deposit
but
22b
is the
um is the charitable game naming horse
historic horse racing which is a slot
machine right or as near to it as you
get there the owners are calling them
slot machines now um
and does
that relate to what is going on in this
bill namely will the um will all of your
three be
taking that
um I guess it would be particularly be
Churchill Downs be taking bets uh on on
historic horse in historic horse racing
machines and producing a and having
accounts that people could put money
into and then play those machines until
they run out of
money um is that part of this de no AB
absolutely not so ADW is well ADW for
one is sort of is separate and walled
off from all other types of gambling so
this that particular
provision grants rulle making authority
to Lottery it just adds now ADW it has
no impact with respect to what already
exists for HHR and as you know HHR is
limited um to certain a certain number
of facilities currently physical
locations and express bet doesn't have a
physical location uh um you know that
Churchill Downs has a physical location
but what they do at that physical
location is entirely separate from ADW
um so ADW operates sort of in its own in
its own lane where in the law does that
happen where does what happen I'm sorry
sorry follow on that ADW is totally
separate from everything except um well
you're using it for live horse racing
only but right I mean that's well that's
laid out here in this particular bill um
it's with ADW is specifically with
reference to
paramutual um wagering on live horse
racing according to the interstate horse
racing act and that's it that's all this
covers that's the very first line top of
the bill
it's but where um okay where what do you
are the interstate horsing in compliance
with this
section and the interstate horse racing
um
because when they put historic horse
racing into the law they put it in the
racing section and I have a great deal
of difficulty differentiating what
applies across
yeah the two of them they are very
different things I guess again what I
would say to that is currently ADW is
not addressed in state
law this would add a section specific to
ADW all other forms of gambling um that
currently take place in the state
already exist in law there are sections
specific obviously the charal game into
HHR and all those things this is
entirely separate and would exist
okay um yes represent fellows thank you
I have two questions uh one of them is
short answer um the age for
participation in this bill is 18 and I'm
just wondering if you might know the
other states that you deal with if the
age is 18 or if it's something else and
my other question is the entity that
owns your business um Express
bets do they have um subdivisions that
are involved with any other kinds of
wagering or gambling yes so first
question age that I don't know the
answer to I assume it's I assume it's 18
I think um the way this bill was drafted
was using sort of other state sources as
a sort of as a foundation or a template
um so I assume in other states it's most
likely the age is 18 that may be a
product of federal law as well I don't
question remind me again I'm sorry it
has to do with the business structure
that oh yes I'm comp you're in yeah so
Express beted is a subsidiary of a
larger company that larger company has
other companies involved in other in
activity okay um thank you very much for
your test oh did I miss one ah
representative shamber your dad's not
color Pine is
he Mr chairman thank you I don't think
your daughter heard that I it's all
right I'm not color blindest oh okay
because we do have red lights in this
state sir okay uh regarding uh
Representatives do said about uh
business
models uh does Express bets believe in
the New Hampshire charitable gaming
approach as part of their business
model meaning meaning money going to
Charities money going to benefit other
organizations and people in the state I
mean I I think that's a great thing we
obviously support the bill as it exists
today with money going to the Charities
I will tell you in other states uh
passing similar licensing and in
regulation um there has been a similar
move I'm familiar with at least one
state I remember exactly where it is but
also in that case when they license and
regulated ADW they send that money to
charity as well so it's not um it's not
a novel concept obviously not in this
state either so we do support it uh but
to the extent and there's been many
questions obviously about the charitable
piece of this uh to the
extent that's sort of a a sticking point
or it causes
confusion we're most concerned obviously
peace okay thank you very much for your
testimony thank
you and uh I've got one more pink card
it is Michael Haley from the Department
of
Justice good morning Mr chair and
honorable committee members my name is
Michael Haley I serve as the Director of
charitable trusts at the Department of
Justice I'm here just to speak about the
charitable aspect of this
bill um I don't have any uh any
knowledge about the the lottery aspect
of this bill um our office the
charitable trust unit is charged with
protecting the Public's interest in
organizations and assets dedicated to
charitable purposes in New Hampshire um
and there are currently approximately
5,600 uh New Hampshire based Charities I
realize that was a question earlier on
um we don't take any position on the
bill I'm just here to provide some
information U particularly about some of
the wording relating to the charitable
component of this bill that uh could be
read as inconsistent with other laws and
if the committee was planning on U
moving forward with a bill might want to
look into those um I essenti I have
pretty much Four Points to mention
they're all on page four of the bill um
so I'll go through those and I'm happy
to take any questions about any of
those um the first point is on page four
um lines three and five um this this
section of the bill refers to the the
charitable intermediary organization and
requires that it not have an owner or
operator who also owns or operates a
charitable organization participating in
charitable grant program um the concern
here is that Charities don't have owners
um by definition the assets of a charity
belong to the public because the public
is the ultimate beneficiary so I I
suspect that the intent here was to
prevent a director or officer of a chair
it someone who perhaps on the board an
executive director a Chief Financial
Officer someone like that associated
with the charity from uh holding one of
these positions if that's the case I
would suggest that um that uh words such
as um uh director officer or trustee
would be more in line with how uh
charitable assets are are
held um the second point that I would
like to raise is on line 12 of page 4 um
and it refers to there being no carry
forward of unused eligible contributions
in the first program year I'd just be
curious what the plan would be for any
uh assets that were not used um I'd want
to bring to the committee's attention a
US Supreme Court case that uh originated
in New Hampshire the trustees of
Dartmouth College versus Woodward it's
an 1819 case so quite old but still a
good law that places some restrictions
on what uh the government can do with
funds that have gone to a charity um and
so in this case uh I don't know what the
plan would be if there was money left
over if that was going to be taken back
by the state you would want to be
careful about uh that particular Supreme
Court case I'll just interrupt you for a
second represent that wasn't line
12 just gonna say I think we must be
looking at different versions maybe I I
apologize do I have an old version of
the bill I I have a a line that says
there shall be no carry forward of
unused eligible contributions am I in
the wrong that's line okay uh I'll I'll
stop referring to lines because I
imagine I have the wrong version then um
is there a a line in the current bill
that talks about maintaining separate
accounts for charitable funds and
operating funds 11 that's 11 okay uh so
on on line 11 then um the uh all funds
of a 501c3 are charitable funds by
definition so uh I'm not entirely sure
what the intent of this this line was um
and uh perhaps uh if the intention was
to delineate the grant funds versus the
operating expenses that uh Grant funds
would be a more accurate description
here of of what's Happening um and then
I'm assuming the next line below that
not award a charitable Grant to any
lineal descendant or equivalent step
person of any officer director or
employee of any charitable third party
Financial intermediary um here you would
want to be careful about uh any language
suggesting that a charitable Grant could
go to an individual I believe that the
intent here is that the charitable uh
the intermediary we' be making grants to
other Charities um and a charity must be
designed to uh to benefit the public and
not to benefit private individuals so uh
again if the intent here was to limit uh
prevent the charitable grants from going
to any organization that had as a
director officer or trustee a lineal
descendant um then the committee may
want to consider language that made that
that clear um and uh just and as a
general comment from reading this over
with a limited background and limited
time um I didn't see a definition of
advanced deposit wagering in it which
would have aided me in in trying to
review uh what this bill was trying to
do that's not really pertaining to the
charitable section and and it may be
elsewhere in law I only got this
yesterday afternoon so I apologize if
that is defined
somewhere um could you um give or email
a version of your proposal certainly
changes thank you is that you
want yes uh this is the clerk speaking
you went 78 RPM I can only type at 33
RPM so if you could provide that
material that
would okay yes represent Aly would it be
worth asking him if he could redraft
those sections for us to take a look
at instead of just commenting on what we
need to change but change it to
what I I could certain I I would have to
get uh approval from our office about
providing specific Bill language but I
could certainly look into that okay
thank you representative spillsbury
thank you um I thought those uh comments
seem to be well taken except I'm a
little confused on the first of your
four comments so on line one in page
four the words not have an owner or
operator dot dot dot that doesn't relate
to the charity that's receiving the
grant right it relates to a char a a
third party Financial intermediary the
one who's going to make the allocation
decisions so I'm not sure why I'm not
sure what your objection is uh the thank
you for the question the concern is that
that charitable intermediary also can't
have an owner there's no such thing as
the owner of a charity and the the
intermediary is required to be a 501c3
organization are you suggesting that the
charitable intermediary M must itself be
a charity I believe that's what the bill
says at least the one that I have it's
in the definition it says that an
intermediary has to be recognized under
501c3 of the Internal Revenue
code um thank you for drawing me to that
thank
ellerie oh thank you that brings up The
Perennial question since New Hampshire
recognizes a lot of things that are
Charities that aren't Charities that are
Charities um
so under the scheme that you're
describing the dispersing agency would
have to be a
501c3 now 501 c3s are then restricted to
c3s so uh thank you for the question 501
c3s are restricted to carrying out their
their um charitable
purposes um there are charitable
organizations that make distributions um
to entities that are not recognized as
501 c3s for example um there are trusts
the purpose of which is to make
distributions to a particular church and
the churches typically are not
recognized under 501c3 as tax exempt
even though they are they are tax exempt
entities they're they do not have 501c3
status so uh it could I I'm not an
expert on federal tax law I could see
there potentially being concerns about
distributions made to the 501 C4s the
sixes the 10s the 19s that um that New
Hampshire in some circumstances also
calls Charities that would have to be
something that the um the third party
intermediary would want to uh be careful
about I suppose um when seeking their
501c3 tax exemption and Reporting their
distributions to the
IRS followup
follow well there's a lot more than that
involved um although you did hit on the
the points regarding that particularly
in New Hampshire where our definition of
charity is not very clear um but let's
just take a uh uh I think a C4 which is
an educational I think C4 is educational
is it social welfare organization social
well there's several social
welfare six 8 10 uh
but let's let's take a a
school so you have a
school and it may
be it's not profit because it's a
educational facility but it maybe it's a
um we'll go with B own Catholics because
it's
stereotypical um May maybe they're
running gaming to support presentation
of Mary down in Hudson could the
distribution agency then distribute
them to to a school to a a which is not
a 50 1
C3 um the language in this bill does not
preclude that I imagine that the
organization who that has this uh
recognition as a thirdparty intermediary
would need to be careful about how it
did its federal taxes to determine if
those distributions were consistent or
inconsistent with the 501c3 purpose okay
another followup followup uh
finally who's going to oversee the
distribution agency and how much is that
going to cost
uh thank you for the question so if if
this is a 501c3 that is based in New
Hampshire or does business here it would
be required to register with and report
to the director of charitable trusts um
we uh would not typically get that deep
into the operations of a charity to
determine if every distribution that was
made was consistent with federal tax law
that's usually the irs's role um what
they would report to us is their their
IRS filings um their board uh
information their governance procedures
things like that um I suspect that
there's some role for the Lottery
Commission here as they're the ones who
are choosing um this third party
intermediary and who and whether they
would relicense them in the follow in
any following year um and there's a
reporting to the Lottery Commission
listed in this bill from my
understanding um but they would be
required to register and report to to
our
office representative Malloy thank you
Mr chair thank you Mr Haley for taking
my question uh this
may or may not be relevant to this
conversation but you mentioned that if I
think I caught this if a charity
501c3 uh goes out of
business you said the that the
beneficiary of that what's left of the
assets I think goes to the general
public is that because in many if I may
my my experience is that in in many
cases there is a uh plan laid out by
many of the 501c3 to go to a succeeding
organization or another
organization uh that's could you help me
with this sure I apologize if my comment
was not clear um what I was trying to
say was that uh a charity does not have
any owners so a typical Corporation the
members of the board of directors have
some ownership interest in the in the
chair in the organization and oftentimes
when the organization dissolves the
board of directors gets to keep
whatever's left around um they have some
kind of ownership stake in it um or the
share holders or whoever um with a
charity the ultimate beneficiaries of a
charity have to be the public and not
any individual so it's not possible to
have a an organization formed for
charitable purposes where if it
dissolves the board members or the
members get to retain those assets
typically as you said uh when a charity
is formed it's required to have a
dissolution provision that's part of
their articles of agreement that are
filed with the secretary of state and
those must say that the upon dissolution
the assets go either to another 501c3 or
a government entity they are free to
prescribe more specifically if they have
a particular charity in mind or a
particular government entity but it at
best it must go to a c another C3 or uh
our government entity thank you you you
you got to my question thank you yeah
thank you um let's U Get representative
fellows let's try to we're way over
let's try to wrap up
quickly so I have a question about this
structure that's in the bill says that
the state will give the money transfer
the money to a
501c3 which is a charity and when they
fill out their
$199 is that the right number um they
are they going to show the money that
the state gives them
as making a CH doing charitable work and
then will the second
501c3 that the town that gets the money
for the football field or whatever
they're also going to show those same
dollars as charitable work which is kind
of double
counting thank you for the question um
so uh the I believe the form you're
thinking of is the the 990 the the IRS
form 990 um the IRS form 990 uh notes
the the General Revenue um it does not
provide a particularly detailed
breakdown of where money uh comes from
specifically so um sometimes uh there I
believe there's a line that says
government grants and I I suspect that's
where this would be categorized um
within the IRS form 990 there is a
schedule B that is filed with the IRS
but not filed with our office because it
is um it's confidential information that
we're not entitled to the schedule B
provides more detailed information about
specific donors specific organizations
that give grants and we don't have
access to that information so follow up
so I'm last last follow I'm asking about
when that the the identified charitable
third party Financial
intermediary sends the money to the the
more local entity that um is getting is
the re is this end that's going to spend
the the money when they do that are they
reporting that as a
charity yes they would also be reporting
that as as charitable income but that's
not a very unusual setup there are a lot
of organizations that are set up to
receive grants and then make sub grants
and sometimes those Sub grantees make
further sub grants that's not an unusual
um setup for a charity can I just have
one more followup um no I'm going to end
it now thank you Mr Haley thank you very
much I will send you an email with those
you I yes represent I just add one ask
sure director of Lottery director
Sor good good morning Mr chairman
members of the committee Charlie
McIntyre director of the lottery with me
is our uh director of sports betting
Danny
Maloney thank you representative Aly
thank you could you just provide for me
where in the racing statutes it on says
that on
this on that only live racing would be
covered by ADM ADW whatever it
is I mean certainly historically ADM has
only been live racing and so and current
it exists in that form only the three
operators that had been in New Hampshire
which is now to only ticket on live
racing and the players only want it on
live racing um you you couldn't do it on
historic racing because everyone would
cheat um you know nobody would not bet
on secretary at the Belmont um they you
know you would research your phone and
you would so it would be not a viable
product I don't think and certainly if
it's a concern for the legis we can fix
that in Ru making in terms of it has to
be a live wager but it's the only way
it's done currently now that I'm that
I'm aware of uh and there 28 states
where it exists yeah so in our laws in
the historic past before it came to
live correct
correct okay thank
you um
okay well since we have a new a new
speaker here um representative shamberg
followed by representative Ames thank
you Mr chairman and thank you director
McIntyre does Lottery support this
Senate Bill 432 now that you've heard a
lot of this discussion
today do you have any other opinions on
it
um so by and large the lottery never
supported the expansion of gaming which
this the end of the day looked like it
was a little bit it's really the
recapturing of gaming but certainly
we've never historically said we're in
favor of gaming we did ask Senator Lang
to look at this in terms of clarifying
what had been a practice that existed um
because in many ways um we would rather
have that regulated market versus an
unregulated market and number of reasons
not just for the fact that there's
revenues to the state but also consumer
protections um in an unregulated Market
that consumer is the one who doesn't
benefit really because there's no
appeals process with the state with us
um and certainly similarly when we were
appro we approached the Attorney
General's office regarding fantasy
sports and we thought fantasy sports was
not legal DraftKings and FanDuel went
and had a bill passed and fantasy sports
was UN legalized in the state which we
now regulate followup Mr chairman
followup uh have you had this bill
reviewed or not the
bill has the AG's office uh reviewed the
legality of
ADW here in this state and that's why we
have this outcome of this legislation
would you say correct it was when we
approached the topic with the Attorney
General's office it was suggested then
that we clarify it by a bill which would
clarify and be based on other bills in
other states that also clarified
it thank you Mr chairman thank you
repres
Ames on the charal uh it's not charal
gaming the uh chable part of this bill
that was inserted apparently in
executive session in the Senate's
deliberations and um my question is
whether you think that that uh is a
workable model and if the numbers that
there have been assumed 200 roughly
$200,000 are in the ballpark I mean
certainly anything's workable um you
know I I often say we don't make policy
with the instruments of policy and so if
it's the legislator and the governor's
wish to do this then we'll certainly
administer it the best we
would over 200,000 yes yes I think
that's right I will tell you that
historically when you legalize a
activity it tends to grow the
revenue not that this is a problem area
you know this is not like sports betting
was where it's a bookmaker and a sports
bar um but if you legalize the market
you tend to grow it thank you
representative D I don't mean to belabor
this but thank you for taking my
question director but we heard some
testimony from someone earlier that
stated that the Lottery Commission has
no authority to regul at ADW is that
your position the lottery has no
authority to regulate ADW at present I
think that's a finer Point than that uh
representative and thank you for the
question um current ADW that exists now
we have the authority to regulate the
ability to regulate what is online
gaming and horse racing for ADW I think
was in a I hate to use the words gray
area but was in a gray area the lottery
has the authority to promulgate
regulations regarding Advanced deposit
wagering and it doesn't clearly find
that that Authority pre-exists the
internet and so it's one of those areas
where we haven't cleaned it up to comfor
technology so that ansers your question
quick followup I know we have to move on
so 284 RSA 284 and parool
525 doesn't lay it out clearly enough it
does it doesn't so there are certain
laws that exist pre-exist the internet
and pre-exist online and so
certainly in the abundance of caution
candidly I would rather seek the
approval of the legislature for doing
something than doing it myself be if
that makes sense follow up I don't mean
to belabor this and thank you for the
followup um do you know when the power
pool 525 rule came into place it was
well into the internet age if if my
information's right about 98 99 I
honestly there was before my time and
thank you very much all right I'm going
to
there okay um we need to get going right
away we will I will open the public
hearing on S SP
546 and is there someone here to
okay morning Mr chair
I think my pink card is making its way
towards
you thank you chairman janigian and
honorable members um for the record my
name is Senator Deborah iller I
represent Senate District 24
representing the towns of exitor stratum
Hampton Northampton Hampton Falls and
Ry um the land and Community Heritage
investment program otherwise known as
lchip has invested $58
million through 564 grants in 198 New
Hampshire communities thanks to the work
of this program that preserves and
protects our past so that future Granite
Staters will be able to connect to our
rich and storied Origins as we evolve
into our future 170 historic structures
acres of land have been
conserved as with any program evolution
is necessary and the bill before you
Senate Bill 546 is an effort to ensure
the grant-funded programs have
enforcement Fidelity that accurately
reflects the processes under which the
elip program functions I am pleased to
bring Senate Bill 546 with the wind at
its back having come out of committee in
the Senate with unanimous recommend
ation of ought to pass and a passage on
the cons consent calendar while I am
thrilled to have had the experience of
serving on the board of directors for
the past year and a half the details of
Grant applications Awards and
managements are still relatively new to
me and I am on the upswing of my
learning curve so I am also thrilled to
have El Chip's executive director Paula
Belmore and board chair Ben Willcox here
with me to provide the precise answers
to questions you may have about the
proposed changes to RSA 227
M3 and thank you for your time and
attention this morning I will turn over
those questions to them if that's okay
yeah that's that's fine yes thank you
thank
you thank
great good morning and thanks for
allowing me to speak this morning um my
name is Ben Wilcox I'm the chair of
lchip and I've been on the board of
directors since uh
2017 so um I'm here to express the
board's support for sb4 uh
546 um the El chip board includes four
legislative seats appointed by the
Senate President and Speaker of the
House these seats are currently filled
by Senators Bradley and Al Schiller and
representatives eel and ren Zulo all of
who sponsored this bill since its first
uh round in 2001 elip has been highly
effective and as a result enjoys broad
public support and perhaps as a test
Testament to the good work of the Blue
Ribbon committee that led to its
creation the original framework for the
program stands for the most part as
adopted however over the last 23 years
best practi practices in land
conservation and historic preservation
have evolved based in part on our
experience with the various types of
legal Arrangements used to accomplish
the program's goals some we've learned
work well and others not so well that
evolution of thinking has led to the
need for SB
546 which seeks to remove a requirement
that the state be granted an executory
interest in each lchip funded easement
to secure the Public's in investment the
lchip statute places three specific
requirements on lchip funded e on an
easement first it must uh be held by a
qualified entity second it must be held
um in public trust by the state and
third it must Grant an executory
interest to the state El Chip's program
rules add a fourth requirement that elip
rtain illegal right to enforce any any
easement and funds further protecting
the Public's interest so that's four
four areas to focus on the bill before
you today seeks to remove the third of
those four requirements the executory
interest but leaves the other three
Protections in place um after Consulting
with the Attorney General's office at
length we understand that the executory
interest requirement isn't necessary to
protect the Public's investment that
investment is well protected by the
other three
requirements as stated in the memo from
the Department of Justice that has been
provided to you removing the executory
interest requirement will not diminish
the state's ability to protect its
investment and uphold the public trust
so in closing I just like to reiterate
that the lchip
board supports this change and we urge
the committee to vote ought to pass for
S SP
546 which will reduce the administ ative
burden placed on lchip the state the
grant recipients while retaining the
state's ability to defend the Public's
trust
investment um today I have uh Paula
bellamore here the executive director to
help me answer any questions along with
attorney Alan Brooks from the Department
of Justice so I guess we can open it up
to questions thank you I guess I have um
I have two questions um to start um we
talk about the executory interest not
being needed I understand the the
thought behind that but there's two
other areas that have changed here in
this bill the first being on line five
the word acquire being crossed out and
the word provide
funding um that seems to me like a major
change because now
where how are they providing how is Ela
providing funding I guess that's a
certainly thank you for your question
since the beginning of the program elip
has not directly acquired interests
instead we provide a grant to a sub
agency who then acquires that interest
for example a land trust or a community
a town so um what I can tell you from my
research and reading is that when the
elip program was first introduced sp sp
401 it actually did propose that elip
would first acquire resource and then
convey it to a partner agency such as a
land trust that was changed during the
legislative process to a becoming a
grant making program which we are today
and is how we've always operated I think
it was just a you know a scer error
level um mistake we have never acquired
directly um
resources okay um and I guess my second
question is on line
27 um acquisition of
resource assets or related and now it's
um
I'm sorry draw upon funds for the
acquisition of now it's draw upon funds
for program purposes that seems like a
much
broader thank you yes it is it is
broader although um I would point you to
the original statute or the to RSA 227 M
which does have other program purposes
Beyond acquiring resource assets for
example historic Rehabilitation which is
you about 50% of our program work and
isn't isn't doesn't require the
acquisition of assets so we're simply
trying to clarify that the program
purposes which are spelled out in
statute are we draw upon funds for those
purposes thank you um representative
Southworth uh thank you Mr chair mainly
for the chair would we say that most of
these changes really are in the area of
housekeeping if really you're not going
to see much difference from the outside
but we're more clarifying on what's was
in the previous legislation
that's what I'm trying to determine yeah
yeah I think uh I don't want to make a
definitive statement on that right now
because we're trying to get to that
elme oh I thought I turned it on sorry
on on line 13 on you've
removed the legal obligations attached
in perpetuity and that's a very
important part but is it just considered
to be part of the easement
interests thank you for the question um
easement interests should be recorded in
the easement deed but there are other
legal obligations that are grantees
accept for example an obligation to post
signs on the property or to acknowledge
the El chip Grant to monitor the
property on an annual basis those
obligations aren't appropriate in a real
estate deed they are memorialized in a
grant contract or a grant agreement that
we enter into so it's along the same
lines of the first two changes we've
doing yes representative Bolton thank
you Mr chair this just a clarification
so on line 16 of page one it says the
authority is authorized what's Authority
in reference to elip is an independent
authority of the state so in the statute
the program is or the the board is often
referred to as the authority
and I think um attorney Brooks would
probably be more appropriate to explain
what an authority is as opposed to the
program in the board because it's okay
above my pay pay grade thank you
representative fellows thank you um I
might understand this a little bit
better if I knew what
executory whatever is um but in terms of
Deeds so am I correct in assuming that
lchip may makes Deeds for conservation
easements so I think your first the
two-part question your first part is is
would probably be helpful for a lot of
people an executory interest is a
contingent future right of in a in
property so it's a right that can be
exercised based on certain future
conditions so in other words the state
could hold the easement or take the
easement if certain conditions had been
met those conditions would be for
example if the land trust stopped
enforcing and attorney Brooks can get
into the details of why they already
have that right under public trust but
essentially that's what an executory
interest is it's often um in the land
conservation Community people think that
an executory interest is simply a right
to enforce it is not it is a right to
actually hold the property or the
resource asset so it's a very important
difference um and the second part of
your question was oh Deeds so elip does
not convey property because we never
acquired the property instead we provide
funding to an entity who then purchases
the property usually from a private land
owner so we award a grant to the land
trust they use that money to buy an
easement on a farm so the deed is being
conveyed from the farmer to the land
trust elip is a party to that because we
take a right of enforcement to ensure
that we can uphold the investment the
state's investment but we aren't
actually conveying
or accepting the
deed follow
up so I'm trying to figure out the way
you're doing it or suggesting to do it
if if the farmer is holding the
deed do
it what happens if he sells it
and you know somebody wants to like
build houses on it sure so is there will
there be something in the deed that says
you can't do that and if you try to do
that the state's going to get it back or
right so with an easement it's almost
like you have two layers of ownership so
you have owner of the land the property
and then when we acquire an easement
we're taking a portion of those property
rights which are for example the right
to build houses on it and that's what
the land trust acquires so then you have
two
Deeds remembering that a deed is a legal
document right so you have two documents
one is the title deed to the property
which the farmer still holds and the
other is the easement in the property
which is held by the land trust and that
runs with the land so no matter who owns
it that easement
stands follow up so I I thought that
easements were in a deed are you saying
it's a separate document or is it like a
second chapter or something an easement
deed is a separate document from the
title deed or the from the fee deed so
if you owned land that had an easement
on it there would be two Deeds there
would be the the deed to the property
itself and the easement deed I I think
in attorney Brooks could correct me I
think it's possible to have it all
rolled into one I'm not sure um about
that but two different pieces of paper
i' I think I've seen it all rolled
into yeah I mean I I've definitely Deeds
where it's all rolled into one but it
could be as she says separate it could
be separate Mr chairman yes just just to
clarify it's typical that someone will
already have acquired a property and be
the owner and deed was recorded to
document that
transfer now at some point in the future
while owning it that owner may choose to
Grant an easement could be to the power
company could be to the town could be
for conservation purposes there's a wide
range so they're they're most ordinarily
separated in time and uh the one becomes
subject to the
other thank you uh representative Malloy
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking this
question is this an example of what we
did in Greenland with the southeast land
trust and the El chip situation because
this is great because it's the first
time I've really understood the whole
thing with your your testimony that's
that's my question thank you um thank
you for the question yes in the case of
the um Farm in Greenland the southeast
land trust and Brian Hart their
executive director happens to be here
today um received an elip Grant which
they will use I don't think that has
closed
yet April 30th um and they'll use those
funds to acquire an easement um just as
was explained the farmer already owns
the land but will sell the easement y
followup follow
it you're right it is April 30th and I'm
also a trustee of trust funds and I need
to uh we need to make sure you get a
check by the end of this month thank
you represent
elberger thank you Mr chair and this is
not a question it's just a a thank you
um I represent Nashua and for those of
you who are looking at the back of this
there are two projects in nashille I
just want to let you know what they are
the Sacred Hearts School has been turned
into a new home for the Nashua soup
kitchen and shelter uh in addition to
the soup kitchen there are dormitories
for men single men and single women as
well as apartments for mothers and
children uh it is a wonderful facility
and the sullan farm has a large apple
orchard and they also have one of the
biggest solar panel arrays that I have
seen that's not set out in a field
uh also wonderful uh suven Farm is in my
ward and I invite any of you to come
down take a look anytime you're
interested thank you thank
you
um okay thank you very much thank you
thank you the last pin card I have is uh
Brian
that is there anyone else who would like
to testify that's all I have for pink
cards seeing none we'll close uh the
we are uh way behind we're about 50
see let's let's uh let's get started
we'll get started on some of the work
session work to see how we're
doing need
see I'm going to open the work session
472 relative to Historic racing
licensing establishing operations of
games of chance for the benefit of the
host community and relative to
charitable gaming for municipalities and
charitable
472 representative
Southworth H thank you Mr chair I'd like
to start where we kind of ended last
time which was with all these waiting
lists um which we were trying to double
check were there in fact going to be any
slots open to municipalities
really that's um that's a good question
um represent Aly would you like to take
that well we forgot to ask the relevant
people if we had them here but I was
assured
yesterday that this would be
um
apply I'm trying to remember exactly
um well he's asking if the towns uh or
cities would have a chance oh yes at
this yes he that was it um that that he
was assured that legally the not
withstanding any provision of law to the
contrary which is what I thought in line
seven of page two is
um
on rules over everything that follows it
in that set in that
subsection uh in 4 a namely
that because it's not withstanding any
provisional law to contrary on the game
operators are
required um to annually operate a
minimum of seven but not more than game
10 game dates for the benefit of the
town or city
on rules over at least that's the way I
understood it sections Roman 2 3 and
4 that would allow the
charity to all the the Charities
to acquire
time
that now maybe I misunderstood it
yesterday but
um that would in insist that the
municipalities be involved in
this
um
okay all right uh going to go to
representative ducet and I I think can
maybe more directly address
representative southworth's question I
personally think it's a moot point and
from the information that I'm getting
there are so many Charities I don't
believe there'll be that uh opportunity
for municipalities to capture this um I
and I spoke to some of my counterparts
here I've spoken to an attorney that
tells me that this language is Rock
Solid um and that the charities will get
the preference we have waiting lists
it's not
geographical um so it's my firm belief
that we're not going to see this effect
on the
municipality anytime soon because that
was as you well aware that was my major
concern so I'm I'm not necessarily
concerned with that any
longer thank you representative Aly and
then follows yes I do not understand
that the not withstanding any provision
of law to the contrary because we all
know that if there are any game dates
open still in uh in the the game
operating
schedules they're they must be in
Berlin which doesn't produce very much
money uh for the charity that would take
it from Lebanon say
so
so Roman
1 says the game operators have to
provide a minimum of s days annually to
the city or town where they are and two
impossible represent to7
my my understanding is that first
sentence not withstanding any provision
of law to the contrary right now in law
it's goes to a
charity goes to a charity first and
foremost and if the there is the charity
list is exhausted or another charity
can't be and I contend we have plenty of
Charities and they will continue to
apply that supersedes
anything thereafter yes and that's what
with that I don't agree with because it
says not withstanding law that already
exists but the notwithstanding would
also I would presume the notwithstanding
would also refer to even this if it
passes
um representative
Ames it doesn't that mean there all this
language is just a waste of space um
that uh there's
um post communities are not are not
saying yeah that's what you're saying um
because of the numbers of Charities that
were out there and the waiting list and
all that stuff means
that although this sounds nice host
communities aren't going to get anything
right do I have it right I I totally
agree and I think
uh wh whomever authored this it may make
that person um happy to see that as a
fallback I don't believe it's ever going
to become that fallback so
I my my feeling is that given that
that's the
case that within this Frame that we're
talking about here this language should
not be here it's just confusing uh if
anything and um it should be amended out
out on the other hand I also think that
there is legitimacy to the notion that
host communities incur costs and uh
there should be some way of providing
for that um it's an issue that comes up
it was an issue I remember that was
addressed in that big gaming bill that
I engineered years and years ago um host
communities incur costs and it's often a
debated issue because some people think
casinos sort of
engender other kinds of activities and
that and people argue about that but
still I think basically there's going to
be a call for police response to issues
arguments that develop on site and uh
and so forth and more cars and just it's
natural it's going to happen um and
money is floating around so um I I feel
that issue needs to be addressed I
suspect it's going to be uh considered
how it's going to be addressed I don't
know it comes back to that gaming
commission that I happen to sit on uh
you're on it too and um we'll be working
through that um so one of the puzzles
that I have as we look at bills like
this is do we really need
this um as we're we know that in
parallel to this process there's
something more comprehensive that's
digging a little further into the issue
I think the one one part of this that's
needed relates to the
moratorium um there if we continue to
fail to pass legislation on
the uh restriction of licenses to a
finite group of
entities um we as a legislature and
Governor working together then
we're going to roll by June 30th and
there'll be no restriction that's my
understanding um so um I feel we need to
do something we've already sent one bill
to the Senate it's still sitting there
as far as I can tell 112 Senate Bill
112 um and in that one I think you you
helped to engineer the representative
set um and that uh that one uh froze the
number of uh entities at the uh the
original whatever 15 or whatever Plus
those in the pipeline as of a certain
set of dates and uh and that does the
trick that sets that contains this this
bill um has
a has an end dat to that new Arrangement
um seven years out if I remember
correctly and that's I guess work well
it seems a little long to me but um you
know I I've learned to be flexible in
this business um and uh so that's the
one piece of this I may be missing
something else that's essential and we
could uh we could amend this bill
and and um send it to the floor and if
it came came out it could be just
focused exclusively on the uh this issue
of um of uh
uh moratorium this moror the limits uh
issue and uh drop the other stuff I
don't know whether we'd be dropping
important stuff I I just put that out
there that we maybe need to focus on how
we get to what we've got to get to um
and push that issue and maybe deal with
these other things too I don't know I
just I've talked too much representative
you said if I may and I I know we're in
agreement with this and I I think the
moratorium is the important component
here and it allow for us to have that
time we've spoken about many times to
review and and find out where this is
going where where we are right now and
also to this language specific to the
municipalities I may think it's
moot you may think it's
unnecessary somebody thinks it's
important enough to put in there and and
for for the sake of argument yes the
municipalities take on incur a cost this
is an acknowledgement at least in this
piece of legislation of that and and
that's and then we need to work towards
in the commission but I don't think
there's a need I I think we should take
this this piece as written move it
forward so there's no opportunity for
the other body to yet again amend or do
something in a committee or conference
that might send the sideways because we
do not want to allow for June 30 to come
and the Wild West to ensue as far as
HHR so that would be that would be my
personal opinion I I I agree with you
representative D said in fact that that
was my thing one of the reasons I would
like to leave this unchanged is for that
you you spoke about things are getting
delayed and tied up if we pass this as
it is it moves on to the governor this
get us to yes
yeah uh did you have a question
Representative no I was just going to
say that I agree with everything that
I've heard okay uh representative
Southworth yes I agree too I phras it
different at the beginning I do
understand if we just send it back as is
that still may get us where we want to
go yes thank you representative PL I was
just going to say I hate to say I agreed
with representative this said but I do
many have the same
feelings all right I think we will uh
move on from this we'll close the work
out next uh open I'll open the next work
session on SB 432 relative to Advanced
deposit
wagering representative PL
I want to kill this bill to to me that
if this bill got passed it gives a it
gives Credence to the history where
nobody was paying anything and operating
illegally and uh so I want to address
that issue before we pass anything like
this okay representative ducet yeah and
I agree and we've all sat through the
testimony here and what we did with s
sp190 which is the exact same language
here and the money was going to the
exact place in my estimation it should
have went instead of creating another
entity to distribute what funds may be
to what charities may be fact remains is
we have Statute in law right now
everybody that came up here including
the lottery director said this is a gray
area I suggest it's a great area because
somebody dropped the ball here and we we
can't be kicking this can down the road
we we can address it going forward but
the fact remains is everyone's on point
we we had somebody testifying for one of
these people saying they all said it was
legal but they all said it was a a gray
area okay and if it if if it was legal
if it wasn't a problem there's two
outlets still taking bets why are they
here lobbying us to make them pay that
1.25% you know the pieces just don't
come together for me so I I my position
is we itl this and and we get some
action on
this isn't that what I'm sorry Mr
chairman isn't that what this is re
asking us to do put some action on it
now versus kicking it down the road
again what we are asking to to have some
rules and regulations we have rules and
regulations on everything else and here
we're saying ah we're not going to put
rules or regulations here representative
do it's my belief and my contention that
if one particular and I I've called this
out before if one particular AG doesn't
pursue this doesn't necessarily mean
another AG won't pursue this so if it's
legal take the bets you've been put on
point because under what I've heard in
testimony I think you and I
representative should stop start a
website and start taking bets on simal
cast racing today because it's Le legal
it's a ww west because we don't have
Statute in place to to we have written
statute that specifically outlines simoc
cast live racing we have rules that I
quoted earlier that specifically I found
out it was
1997 that uh parool 125 rule came into
place specifically for ADW the there is
one provider in the state of New
Hampshire who can legally take bets and
it goes to the interstate racing act to
states that in order to take a
bet the state in which the bet is made
it must be
legal comply with the laws of that
state the state where the BET originates
it must be legal comply with the laws of
that state it's not happening in New
Hampshire it has hasn't happened in
here representative elme followed by
Olie yeah I also do not understand
why what I do not believe any attorney
general would be following up trying to
accuse these places of a crime so that
they can get a penalty out of them
because I don't think the penalty could
end up being very much
money uh and we can't pass law that's
punitive so we can't get it back that
way um punitive backwards
um
so so I think we might as well go ahead
and get this thing into a
a
legal position I just want to make very
sure that they never put in accounts
online accounts for slot
machines because too many people who
don't have much money could end up
up wouldn't crack this seal
thank
you I I'm I'm really confused and and
when I was talking with the individuals
I hope that was apparent because we got
an argument that
says that it's legal and we have an
illegal and the argument that
representative duett is making says that
we already have rules in place so this
legislation isn't necessary because we
have rules in place but the argument
that the people putting this forward say
we don't
have rules so the question is do we have
rules or don't we have rules and the AG
never answered that so I don't know
where we are do if do we have rules or
don't we have
rules or I shouldn't say rules
laws representative El me we have laws
for live racing we don't have laws for
online
betting of live racing no that's not
that's incorrect that's incorrect parool
and and I'll send you a copy of it yeah
we that was established in
97 lays out what Advanced deposit
okay
follow and it does talk about internet
well know if it specifically talks about
I can send it to you so look yeah that
would be nice we do have R it or we do
have a law we do have and the law talks
about live
racing and it talks about Advanced
deposit wagering is that
correct say again representative duet
representative I believe that's correct
let me pull up this rule here I'm going
question Advanced deposit wagering can
be done in person I think that's what
the law is is indicating at the present
point that you can go to someone and say
I want to put this down and over the
next few week she'll say I'd like to put
this amount of money to them to them on
this race this race this race and
someone will send that off I think this
is our electronic age has put us in a a
little
quandry of how we are going to do at
Advanced deposit
wagering I don't think we have an answer
on it and I think someone is trying to
say let's let's get this clear now and
this would clear up
no I'm I'm going to send it to you folks
but but I brought this issue up
specifically with
Lottery years ago and was told it was
passed on to the AG okay years ago at
least 4 to five years ago I sat with the
AG last year before this legislation
started coming
generated I was told by Lottery was
passed on to the AG when I approached
them four or five years ago I want to
say it's about five years ago when I sat
with the AG the AG said I just heard
about it last month okay I have issue
here somebody dropped the ball if I
wasn't collecting if I wasn't collecting
the revenue correctly let's correct it
but to me there's there's too many too
many missing pieces and I don't think we
should Co cover this up
and and not address what's owed to the
state in revenue and I still go back to
the days I'm from Salem Rockingham Park
these these uh online Outlets
incentivized people not to go to
Rockingham Park not to go to seab Brook
incentivized 5% bet with us online will
give you an extra five bucks on your
hundred okay plus didn't pay the tax so
there's Revenue loss to Brick and Mortar
business here too and if if you can what
you want this this is the truth this is
the
truth representative spillsbury thank
you Mr chairman um separate from and
aside from representative duet's
reservations I think this bill is just
begging to be integrated into a broader
strategy of charitable gaming and that's
why we adopted a bill to create the
commission which is still working on
that subject uh so I think that the bill
has gotten all the more confused by the
addition of the provisions uh in the
Senate executive uh session on
charitable gaming we've got an estimated
$200,000 at stake we have according to
Mr Haley
1,600 charitable organizations that are
potentially
eligible and uh um and we have you know
some sort of a very vague concept of
dispersing equitably throughout the
state I'd like to see this reworked I
don't I'm not sure that these Provisions
even belong in this bill but if they do
I'd like to hear that from the
commission with a more integrated um
plan so I would suggest we um not move
forward with this
bill uh
representative
Southworth uh thank you Mr chair uh just
briefly as we keep going it seems like
there are more questions than answers
which to me says the bill isn't
ready representative fellows um yes I
would uh just like to share with you my
concerns about the um the whole strategy
for that charitable third party being
able to figure out how to distribute
assuming assuming that that they uh had
money to work with um how assuming that
they had 200,000 and they get 10% of
that to do the administrative work to
pass out those grants that that is is
not feasible you can't do that with 20
million
$20,000 and and I'll tell you why
because these are the steps that they
would have to go
through so first step would be they have
to advertise the opportunity to apply
for the grants then they'd have to of
the grants they get back they'd request
um applications they'd have to verify
that the organization was eligible then
they'd have to read the
applications and they'd have to convene
a group of people to rank the proposals
and select some of them you can't you
can't designate that to a single person
to
do and then they'd have to notify the
winner winners they'd have to distribute
the grant money they'd have to have some
kind of audit procedures to make sure
that the money was really being spent
for the particular activity that the
grant asked for the money for and then
for the places that didn't um didn't do
what they proposed to do for whatever
reason youd have to figure out how
you're going to get that money returned
so you can't do that for $20,000 a
year representative shamberg I go back
to representative set again did you send
that yet that what you were looking for
meeting all right but my question goes
to this um
does
ADW uh overlap with any other online uh
uh gambling or is it a separate unit
separate and we're letting Revenue that
we should be getting in the state
here
let's let's go after it let's this bill
sort of puts us on that path toward
it uh
so if you find that information let me
know
Ames double up
his yes representative elberger thank
you Mr chair I um agree with
representative spillsbury
that I that this needs to be part of a
larger
encompassing Bill about dealing with
charitable gaming and
I will therefore agree with
representative Southworth that this bill
is not yet ready for prime time so I'll
not be supporting it thank
you okay thank you I think we're we've
exhausted this one um I'm going to close
the work
59 oh okay
okay I'm going to open the work session
597 uh representative PL yes first of
all this bill does not apply to Lucky 7
that's still done by paper some of them
are this is only with it's done through
a machine and the testimony was that uh
the the people uh requiring to pick out
uh to print out uh tickets is archaic
because people uh playing The Lucky
Seven don't want them they just leave
them there and uh it's Noah the state
requires this and it's harder to get the
um we've got a discussion going on over
here y it's harder to get these machines
that they're becoming difficult to get
so this to me is a no-brain of the
pass
okay any other thoughts representative
uh Southworth uh thank you I agree with
representative PL and I would say
literally this is a housekeeping
Bill okay representative
fellows so you know this is my second
year on this committee and learning
about um all the different games of
chance that we have but my we passed a
bill last year that had to do with the
Lucky Seven tickets and it I think it
allowed people to have more time
something related to the machines I I'm
just getting the impression that these
are just turning into slot machines
that's what it sounds like to me because
there you know first first it was paper
tickets and then it was you could do
paper tickets or on the video screen and
then we did something last year that
made it easier you could play more games
or faster on the video machines and now
we're saying you know let's just get rid
of the Paper Tickets all all all
together I don't think it's lucky s
anymore I think it sounds like a slot
machine representative jet yeah that
that's not the case what what these it's
an electronic version of the pole tab
ticket okay it's they're deal sizes
provided by Lottery there's so many
winners in a deal of say a thousand
tickets it it has no Randomness other
than the deal size itself what this
piece of legislation talks about is in
those electronic versions of the pull
tickets they generate a paper receipt a
paper ticket for lack of a better term
and they end up falling on the floor
because they're useless they just
generate a piece of paper so the paper
Lobby I'm sure is happy about that but
the fact remains is there's no need and
we heard testimony to that this in no
way shape of form changes the game
changes anything about it it's still the
same as if you were going to buy and
pull those three tabs and see if you get
the three bars yeah oh yeah oh yeah and
the machines are an electronic version
of that we we can talk to Lottery if we
want but that's exactly what they
are yes takes eliminates the the receipt
basically I believe that in the hearing
we were told by Valerie King that there
is a requirement that you
cannot uh that the button cannot be
repressed within six
seconds I think it is f three seconds
and the slot machine oh sorry the
historic horse racing machine is how
much that you can do it
in you don't
know
um Miss King do you want to come up here
for a
second what
was
yeah you can ask ask good morning King
with New Hampshire lottery yeah
representative duet could could you
what how the Lucky 7 Draw Works and and
the electronic version of the Lucky 7
machines just so because there seems to
be so many components here in gaming
seems to be some confusion relative to
right now that specific device so if you
don't mind right so uh representative
duet is correct that it is a lucky s
deal has a set number of tickets with a
certain number of winners and losers
which is not the same as a slot machine
which is random uh total random of when
you win or or lose um the amount of time
for the tickets I believe is 3 second
set set by rule and uh historic horse
racing it it doesn't speak to that it it
there is some time in between but it
there's nothing said in in rule or
represent yeah U my concern with with
electronic machines is simply the addic
how addictive is it and I believe that
three seconds of course this is when
they were trying to sell us the historic
horse racing machines uh that uh they
are estimated at 3 seconds
also so um obviously the Lucky 7 machine
doesn't uh
it should be less addictive
but I actually I don't think I've seen
one working I've only been show showed
the portable version we had to agree to
once it sounds like but it sounds like
the main difference is you either get a
receipt or if this passes you don't get
a receipt is that paper paper not a
receipt paper correct and I'd like to
also point out there is only one
manufacturer that I'm aware of that
makes the paper and so they have a
monopoly and that can make it difficult
we we had a time when it was difficult
to even obtain the paper and now we made
it so it was on demand and people aren't
even asking for the paper so effectively
we're operating in a paperless world as
it relates to Lucky 7
okay um okay we all said on this one it
looks good all right close the public
585 work session correct yeah I said
what did I say public hearing okay and I
I don't know what I said previously but
I closed the work session on 597 if I
said public hearing I I apologize uh so
the uh the work session on SP 585 is now
open
representative PL I always stick my neck
out by speaking first maybe I shouldn't
but uh to me this is a good change it
says if they're unpaid uh rooms and
meals taxes it's the managing entity who
should be liable and who uh the state
should pursue not necessarily silent
interests that just have money in it not
no part of actually running the
organization so that that's that's the
intent that's the rment of the bill and
I support it
uh representative
Aly thank you on my only problem with
the bill could be solved by
Amendment on it takes up members and it
says on any person in a managerial
capacity of the limited liability
company or we have we need a definition
of managerial I think on I have a um
acquaintance in Lebanon who this
information about 10 years old now but
has had on 25 different
llc's and about 10 of them now are on on
different
on different
llc's owning each either a gas station
and a
on a gas station and a convenience store
or on he's got one that is a coffee shop
he's got two now that are a coffee shop
and and a car
wash and um he doesn't manage those dayt
day he hires somebody who frequently he
brings up from the guy who is stocking
the shelves to be there and handle the
money on that guy is not I know one of
them quite well is not paid
enough that he would have any money you
could get away from him without putting
him in the poor farm so
um I think that in the case of limited
liability companies you you really need
to Define managerial to be the person
who tell I'm not sure what the legal
language would be but tells um the
people in his employee uh how to do
things or or to add on to this uh any
person uh any
member on holding more than
say 30% of the of the a 30% share in the
business okay I I think we're pres
spillsbury may have an answer for
that I I will come back to that but just
more broadly I think this is a uh
significant bill that we should
pass uh unfortunately it sort of fits
into a very very mky area of Law and uh
I I believe that uh representative oler
during our hearing very constructively
suggested that maybe something that this
committee should put on its dock at the
future is a more comprehensive review of
uh corporate liability limitations of
liability and specifically liability for
tax related uh uh issues but in the
meantime I think the bill makes an
important step in the right
direction the fundamental purpose of
corporate law is to limit liability and
the purpose to limit liability is to
attract investment right so
so this
particular uh law as it
exists essentially carves out an
exception from that and it says not
withstanding normal principles of
limitations of
liability when a business collects meals
and rooms tax which are essentially owed
by the
visitor they're in a fiduciary
relationship they're taking custody of
funds properly due to the state and so
we're going to appear Pierce behind the
veil of corporate uh liability and make
that person responsible for abusing the
public trust okay given that this is a
exception from those normal principles
it should be relatively
narrow and interestingly in the sentence
on lines nine and
10 it is relatively narrow with respect
to
corporations and it's not totally clear
but I take that to mean both C corpse
and sub chapter
S so it says for the purpose of this
section operator in the case of
Corporations includes the president the
treasurer or other person in a
managerial capacity of said corporation
that is excellent language it could be
maybe flushed out a bit more
corporations does in fact include C
Corps and sub chapter
S now what's a sub chapter S without
getting into it it's really just simply
a a it's a vehicle for allowing
incorporation with certain tax
advantages namely pass through um tax
liability well that's essentially where
llc's come into the law LL the whole
point of llc's was to have something
simpler than a C corporation or
pre-existing sub chapter S and so why
then do we in contrast have the current
law saying in the next sentence that in
the case of a limited liability company
operator includes members and any other
person in a managerial capacity I think
it's just a imagine if being a
shareholder of a C corporation subjected
you to having a lean placed on your
personal home because the guy uh in
charge of the
corporation didn't remit the funds
okay the LLC members the passive
investors need the same kind of
protection that a shareholder in a C
Corp has this bill gives it to them now
question um you you brought this up in
the hearing as well and I think it's a
legitimate question but I don't think
actually that the bill is ambiguous on
this point you've made the distinction
more or less I think between somebody
who is operating for sake of
illustration the gas
station but is not himself a member of
the LLC or therefore an owner in the
business but you've got to read this
word so it says person in a managerial
capacity of the limited liability
company so it's not just somebody who's
been hired to manage the gas station
which is one of a chain of 20 this
specifically is limited to and referring
to somebody in a managerial capacity of
the corporate organization the LLC
itself so I I think we we we Illustrated
in the hearing in questions and and
somewhat
now that there are ambiguities in this
field of law but they're not the fault
of this bill and this bill actually is a
step in the right direction and we
shouldn't um hold it up just because the
clear represent
Al yes um I'm talking about people and I
I I in my area I think that it is is
normal um that have multiple Li limited
liability companies but they are the
principal owner of all of them each of
them is legally
separate and as I understood llc's one
of the reasons for starting them was to
have a legal separateness between
several um
businesses so that if if you caused a
major oil spill in one of them they
couldn't collect from your next gas
station because they were two separate
llc's that's absolutely correct but I'm
not sure it in any way defeats the
purpose of this bill the purpose of this
bill is to say who is it what specific
individual is it that we can hold
personally reliable for the failure to
remit mes and Rental tax that was
collected from a visitor or you know um
so you're correct but but in any given
case there is a specific business
entity that has the obligation of
collecting and remitting the meals and
rooms tax and that's what this and you
believe that would be the owner of the
LLC rather than the person in the LLC
who is working for the LLC right when
this when this says managerial capacity
of the LLC that to me by definition
requires that to be the managing member
not any old member and definitely not un
employee okay thank you I I'll just add
that um each year when you file an
annual report with the state you have to
specify who that managerial member is
was that your point well well let me go
to representative fellows I know she's
been waiting for so what I just wanted
to say is now that I've heard it
explained like about three times thank
you for doing that that um that I
understand the concept of man linking
managerial to be a member so it was it
would be a member of the LLC that has
the managerial
responsibilities so I understand that I
don't think this
language makes that clear maybe if if
that's what you're thinking that maybe
it has to be more explicit and say a
member or
members that are have managerial members
who have managerial experience instead
of saying pars with managerial I I think
you're asking a very legitimate question
and if I was drafting this with you I
think we would have chosen different
language but bear in mind that the
problem that you're describing is
largely in the current law and not
introduced by this bill right so I wrote
in my notes during the hearing you know
wouldn't it be better to Define operator
manager managerial capacity sure it
would be a clearer statute if we did
that but I think by definition the
person in a managerial capacity of the
limited liability company can only be a
member so it is bottom line the same
outcome
do you have a followup yes I just I just
would ask if we want to pass this bill
that we fix that just fix that wording I
I think your concern was you'd you if
it's fixed it needs to be fixed in a in
a different I'm suggesting it's not
necessary to fix it I'm also suggesting
that the problem you're pointing to is
in the existing statute not in the
bill
represent yeah that that goes to to my
point as well because if you take a look
at the LLC many of us have llc's if you
take a look at the LLC statute some of
the terms are defined in that this
section is going to go
into uh the LLC section so those
definitions that are already in law
exist now could the LLC statute be more
clear yes but does this say in the
phraseology that was just quoted by uh
um does it
say what we wanted to say and it says a
manager of the
LLC not the manager of the business
being run it's not the shift manager
it's the manager of the LLC which is a
distinct
person uh representative
Southworth thank you just a reminder the
manager is listed on the form that you
have to file and that can't be the gas
station daily person or any of that and
it and it can be a member manager um the
form allows for a member manager or a
manager on the state form that's filed
annually representative Ames I just
think that we've got Dr in the room Dean
Keen Wong is here and I'd like to hear
his his uh he may have other
observations but I'd like to hear from
him regarding this language and how
uh it would work for the Dr or not work
so well or how they might uh fill out uh
some ambiguities just through Ru
making okay yeah Mak sense U Mr
Wong yeah uh I concur with
representative Ames but I just want to
throw one more thought in beforehand so
that Keem can react to it but
I think that in line
11 where this deletes members
and and then deletes other it actually
makes the point clearer the existing
statute is
saying includes
members and other persons well if you're
not a member what what kind of an other
non you know right but removing these
three words makes it more clear that
we're talking about only the member or
members who are in a managerial
capacity so I think it actually improves
on the current law in that respect as
well thank you um please introduce
yourselves good afternoon my name is
Keen Mong text policy council with the
New Hampshire Department of
Revenue and I'm Peter Ro I'm an attorney
with the Department of Revenue
Administration thank
you good afternoon thank you for uh for
taking the time for to here is um we've
been following the conversation and I I
think what uh just wanted to clarify
that the for
llc's the the managers the the the the
persons with the capacity to manage the
the LLC not necessarily would be limited
to just members there could be um
managers that the the members have hired
to manage the LLC so I believe that
taking out the uh the language here um
includes members and uh so the the the
language of members and other and other
so it this therefore operator in the
case of uh of a limited liability
company includes persons in a manag
manager capacity would
include members who are managing as well
as non-members who were hired to manage
the LLC that's how we we read the uh the
language of of the proposed uh Amendment
um and then to sort of assist in um in
this we've try to draft some kind of
language to Define um what a person in a
man manager capacity to be in an
LLC um and I I'll just I I made some
drafts and I'll hand it out
great yeah I think from our perspective
it's important to remember that many
llc's don't have somebody who's a named
managing member they just have members
and so it's it's we have to sort of peel
the onion a little bit and find out
who's actually running the business and
as Keen just said it could be an
employee who's in charge of paying the
tax bill who is neglects to do that um
but that employee may not have any
itself a question Mr
chairman yes for the attorney thank you
uh has there been a a problem for the Dr
in
collecting meals and room taxes from
llc's
here in the
state we we we often have trouble
collecting meals and rentals taxes from
llc's um they tend to be very cash-based
they often their assets aren't wor that
the actually the entity's assets itself
are not worth very much or they have um
leans on them from uh commercial lenders
and uh
employees um and then we find that they
fractionate the business um among
members and so we've had a couple of
instances where you have the brilliant
Chef running the restaurant and the he
brings in his brother-in-law his
brother-in-law's sister and you know
various people to participate in the
business and they all put money in they
often sign a an operating agreement
which is a contract among them which
gives the members uh certain rights to
uh have information and to control how
the business is operated and they often
will sit back and count on the brilliant
Chef to run it and one thing that we've
seen is that brilliant chefs do not make
terribly brilliant business people and
so the BR we had one case where the the
brilliant Chef died and left things kind
of in a state of disarray and the
members who had been letting the
brilliant Chef run it and it was a
relatively successful restaurant they
discovered hadn't paid meals and rentals
taxes in four or five years and so it
was it was kind of a mess to untangle
who was going to be liable for those
I have a question so regardless of who
is who's been hired to manage the
operation or pay the taxes um the M&R
taxes isn't it required on the state
form uh renewing the corporate uh status
to identify a member or a manager the me
if it's a member it's a member manager
and wouldn't that person therefore be
the responsible party
the the forms as I've seen them
um don't exact a great deal of
rigor and they they change members and
managers with some regularity without
necessarily updating the forms that they
submit on an annual basis to the
Secretary of State's
office on that form isn't there a if I'm
remembering correctly there's a spot
where you have to identify who's the
manager whether it's a manager in name
manager yeah they don't they don't list
everybody they only have to list one
person and I don't know that they need
to identify that person as a
manager
okay uh representative
Ames I'm sorry I've looked at a lot of
them and I'm just kind of got a sort of
swirling in my head what they what they
look like and I wish I had the form in
front me but I don't I'm sorry yeah um I
looked at this that you just handed out
um thank you for doing
it I think that this is what we need to
have that my my view uh the managerial
capacity is has filled with the those
two words alone are filled with
ambiguity this uh fleshes
out the meaning of the con ccept without
trying to boil it down to a single word
there are various characteristics that
you look at um and um and the department
makes a judgment based on those various
facts and
circumstances um it's the right way to
go so I would encourage uh moving to get
an amendment to this bill before we go
forward that uh would go down this alley
and uh there are others here who are
more familiar with llc's and this kind
of business than I am so I welcome uh
being told that's not the best way to
go representative spillsbury
um you know within the time and the
constraint of the committee I I I think
representative Ames suggestion is
constructive I think that coming to us
with this draft is helpful this goes
back to what I said when I was listening
in the hearing I made a note to myself
it would be best if we Define operator
manager and managerial capacity so they
are inherently fuzzy um and I think that
the notion of determining who is an
operator for the purposes of this
statute through a consideration of a
range of facts is a good approach as
opposed to you know one specific litmus
test it's kind of like how you determine
doicle or something like that um but
it's a lot more words here than there in
the statute we're amending and we're
only amending it by taking out three
words so is it your intention that this
this is a way of determining the
operator of an LLC only for the purpose
of this one statute or is this an
approach you're thinking is a way to
determine who is responsible for an
llc's activity throughout corporate law
as regulated by the state of New
Hampshire in many statutes thank you
thank you for that question I think our
intention is that this would apply to
this unique circumstances as you pointed
out where this is the exception to the
uh Norm of uh limited liability and
protection from liability of of a
corporate statute um we derived these uh
factors from case law that um involves
uh the Internal Revenue Service and how
it determines whether a person has
personal liability for payroll taxes for
example and so the the case law has has
come up with this seven Factor formula
factors um thank you representative Ames
did you still did you have a follow-up
representative
Ames um my colleague was uh bending my
ear so do you have a followup I'll
follow up to representative spillsbury
okay all right representative PL is it
your contention then that the bill would
be Sol uh would be fortified by putting
this language in in
it or is that something you can do by
rule
making
no I'll I'll let the I'll let Keen
answer that one um I I think it it would
be good to have some kind of guidance
within the statute and then if we do
have um if there's more ambiguity we we
can sort of try to clear that up in in
the rules
um and then because the the there are
instances where um potentially we could
say Okay um what's what's where are the
OS or or jail C might say okay where is
your guidance in terms of where's your
limitation in terms of defining manager
capacity so with with statutory um
language and statutory guidance then we
can if if there is a need to we can
expand for fur or Define further certain
aspects of the followup Mr chair follow
up in the case of the brilliant Chef
up he does that good one
uh representative we'll go this way
represent Aly yes um but I was under the
impression that um a number of smaller
llc's even if they're owned by the same
person on doesn't
is don't doesn't have officers or or a
board so this this would be a pick and
choose what applies in this
case or it would be in everything um
that is correct representative uh not
all llc's would have a board of
directors um and and not all llc's would
have would hire a specific manager to
manage the llc's it could be managed by
the the the uh the manager themselves
so that's why it's very it's a bit
challenging to have a specific as as
representative spillsbury said a
specific limus test to Define okay what
is who is this manager capacity and
that's that's why the the reason for
this
listing and and these factors aren't
intended to be you need to check all the
boxes it could be that one factor could
be dispositive and all the other factors
don't apply or it could be you know
three of them work and not the other
four all right next is representative
ER yes that that follows through the
only comment that there it's one comment
in a couple of different places you're
using the term managerial capacity and
yet in the LLC law a manager is a
specific individual but you're not
talking about that kind of man um member
manager you're talking about a
supervisor
or
supervisory capacity and if you go down
through your laundry
list that's all supervisory activity not
necessarily
LLC
participation capacity that a member
would be a member of that is an
investment member which we're trying to
do is protect the investment members
from the manager from the supervisory
members the members engaged in a I'm
trying to dis distinguish between
capital M member LLC and and man small M
manager doing the job so it's a
supervisory
individual um and your language uh
including but not limited
to seems to cover everything in there
does supervisory meet your definition of
for defrauding the
state thank you for that question I
think the answer is
the these factors would in would include
people who don't have U an equity stake
in the business so it could include the
person who's hired as a manager um and
is resp responsible for making the U
sequestration and and remittance of the
uh taxes that were collected for the
state but failed to do so so it it it's
it's broader than simply getting into
the mechanics of an LLC but it and and
and this is and gets into the sort of
the overall operation of the business
and this is how we've always interpreted
it although you know I think I would say
that you know we're we're not just
despite being the Department of Revenue
we're not unreasonable people and you
know if you said yeah there's a
19-year-old manager who hires and fires
people and and works at night you know
we're going to make him liable no I
don't think so um you know we would look
at at sort of the whole picture and
decide has this person have enough
responsibility that it's sort of fair
and reasonable to make them liable for
the unpaid uh meals and rentals taxes
follow up so let me just follow up if so
if that person if in trying to make that
determination if the person you think is
ultimately responsible is a member and
and let's say this passes and that
person's a
member you could deem them a member
manager and therefore hold them
accountable I I think that's correct if
if a person was a a member but also had
responsibilities in operating the
business or had the opportunity to have
those responsibilities but chooses
basically puts their head in the sand um
we could then treat that person as
personally as an operator for purposes
of this liability okay thank you
ring I am not sure but it seems as
though we're pretty much deep into the
woods that there needs to be more work
on this and I think you can well it
seems to me we might have just come full
circle and and by and by passing this is
not a problem because they can still
determine who is the
managerial uh who has managerial
responsibility and therefore is
accountable I realize we cannot bind a
future legislature we really uh the
legislature capital L needs to take a
look at these rules there's no reference
in this particular Bill to the meaning
of the terms um member and member
manager and all that type of stuff that
exists within the LLC law and making a
connection to this law and the follow-up
question on that was what do you do when
it was done deliberately is that a
criminal action or just is there only
civil penalties
available no it's definitely a crime um
our rules provide that um the funds that
are collected from the customers are
held in trust for the state and if they
are taken from that trust that's an act
of conversion which is essentially a
theft and then in our our criminal code
you know the the RSA 21
j39 uh if I'm not mistaken we I think
there's a a provision in there for
somebody who does steal money from the
state and we've had you know I think we
gave you an example of one but we've had
a a number of successful Criminal
prosecutions of people who take the
money from the customers and uh find
ways to intentionally use it to their
own
benefit representative fellows thank you
um can you tell me what you I'm
wondering if this is being treated
differently than some similar situations
so what if this business hadn't paid its
bet tax would they how would you
determine who to go after and if you I
realize you the attorney for Dr but what
if they don't pay the electric bill or
some other you know
supplier
so we're dealing with a tax here that is
has been called a trust fund tax so this
is a tax on the customer and the and the
the operator that whether it's a hotel
or a restaurant their their duty is is a
fiduciary duty to collect that tax and
give it to us because they're just
really kind of a p through bet and the
other income taxes are a tax on the oper
or the owner's income so you could have
an LLC running a successful restaurant
owe both M&R the meals and rentals tax
and owe business
taxes for us to get personal liability
against a restaurant or business owner
any business owner for the income taxes
is a more difficult and complicated
exercise we have to either pierce the
corporate veil which is complicated or
prove that there was a sham transaction
or that the uh owner was a
transferee of the business assets at a
time when the business was essentially
insolvent so there are specific there's
a specific statute for a couple of those
things and the um the uh Alter Ego you
know pissing the veil is a sort of a
common law theory with some basis and
statute but you know that's how we go
after you know and it's a very unusual
set of circumstances an individual who
um has failed to pay income taxes in a
way that um you know we we find personal
liability ask bet I asked bet
specifically because I didn't want to
get into that let me let me answer that
in the sense that I think what what the
point here is the money collected the
tax collected on
M&R the customer paid that that's that's
that's not the business doesn't have any
uh needs to pass that on to the state
when it's your when it's business income
the
business uh they're paying taxes on
their own business income so it's a
totally different um scenario I think
that's what you're so that's why that's
why I didn't ask about income I asked
about the be tax which is on you know a
percentage of the
employees wages right and and and also
like a supplier well the
bet is is a is an Enterprise Value tax
and one of the ways that we measure that
is on payroll but it's not actually a
payroll tax it's just a the the the
payroll is a a convenient metric for
determining what the Enterprise Value is
I think I got that right thank you I'm a
little out of my league here but I'm
pretty sure that we treat it more like
the income tax as a tax on the business
customers uh representative ORS thank
you Mr chair and thanks for taking my
question so all this conversation sounds
to me like it's it's on the back end I
think the real solution is to put the
emphasis on the front end and companies
like a restaurant let's say Olive Garden
or somebody if they're collecting meals
and rooms tax they should be forced
monthly or quarterly to submit a
documentation and a check right now that
doesn't sound like it's happening so we
wait till after the fact and and if uh
we got suers Chef that Waits four years
you know and he's doing his thing or
she's doing her thing and they're
pocketing the money that's what it
sounds like there's no mechanism to trip
that where if you put the emphasis on
we're going to force them to submit
accordly that's it sounds to me like
that's the answer we just you know let's
get right to the meat of it here um I we
do actually require every business to
obtain a license from us and that tells
us that there's some there's an operator
and it often identifies who the operator
people are and then we require them to
file a monthly return which tells us how
much they took in in tax and how much
they they're turning over to us and then
we have a you know a a web-based portal
that they can file return and make the
payment through um we have you know a
collections department that monitors the
best they can the businesses that we
know about and then sometimes businesses
fly under the radar like like you know
the brilliant Chef I mentioned um and
thank you we do the best we can just
just quick followup I just want to so
you do have somebody monitoring
monitoring these these businesses
because it sounded to me like initially
you were saying and I'm I'm thinking gee
just need somebody then to look at it
but I I guess I'm not sure why how does
it fall I'm going to interrupt you
representative or I don't think that's
the issue at hand okay um the
uh the issue here is members versus
managers and
collectibility of of that should should
they not be paying uh so I'm going to go
to representative spillsbury who had his
light on for a little while thank you Mr
chairman um I believe we have I have in
fact come full
circle and I'm going to suggest as you
said suggested a couple minutes
ago this is a classic instance where we
should rely on the agency to do the rule
making the phrase operator in a m
managerial capacity of the limited
liability Corporation is sufficient for
statutory
purposes in fact amend the bill to
include something that is a seven Factor
sliding scale of which some could be and
some aren't is that's inherently too
fuzzy for legislation and I I'm backing
away from it myself I would like us to
pass the bill as it was sent to us by
the senate i I'd like to just clarify
two things that have come
up the analogy that I used
representative Fells in the hearing was
to the federal income tax employee
withholding
that's a situation which is really more
parallel to this where the
taxpayer has their funds sequestered and
held by in trust right so in in this
case the taxpayer is the person who buys
the meal or buys the
room um we should also therefore in that
context remember that this is just one
hook on enforcing that obligation there
is Criminal
liability um in
my um in the portion of my career in
which I was focused on business
restructure and uh and workout refinance
it was very common to come in and find
that the company that was struggling to
survive was also in a rears on their
Federal um employee tax
withholding and so the very first thing
we put the the focus on in those
engagements was to resolve the federal
tax problem because the consequences are
severe right there is a difference
between something which is overtly fraud
essentially theft from the business
theft of those trust funds for your own
personal purposes it can get much more
ambiguous than that because often it's
just simply a business that is
struggling to stay alive and they've got
a check uh balance they've got an a
balance in their checking account and
they've got a checkbook and they just
start writing checks in the order in
which they think is necessary to survive
and that check to the Dr didn't come up
in the top priority there's there's less
animous less Criminal Intent in that
respect so this is such a confusing area
this bill relates exclusively to one
remedy can we pierce the corporate veil
and put a lean on your home I think we
need to pass the bill and let the Dr
sort out how to interpret those
particular
terms thank you um okay I think we're
almost ready to move on take a couple
more questions or statements
representative Aly yes on and this is
just something that is not on here but
that you mentioned which is um that you
would go after a member who had chosen
not to pay attention to the running of
the business
business if you if you couldn't get
anything out of the manager I guess um
wouldn't that end up with the same
situation that is they are trying to
avoid that um the rest of the members of
the LLC would be
liable because didn't they all choose
if if I understand the question I I
think the answer
is under the as as I mentioned many of
these organizations have an operating
agreement and it's a contract between
the members that establishes what their
rights are with respect to the operation
of the business and those operating
Agreements are
not lodged at the secretary estate's
office and their private agreements and
sometimes the members have them
sometimes they don't but those operating
agreements describe in them what rights
a given member has with respect to
running the business and they often give
them rights to to have information
provided to them so that they can see
that the accounts are being paid
properly and they have rights to um
request an accounting and they have
rights to change the management of the
business and so I think the point that I
was making is if if a member has those
rights
but puts her head in the sand and
decides not to worry about the business
because they're collecting their their
their their share of the profits from
the business all everything seems to be
going well but in fact the actual
manager is is neglecting paying the
Dr then we think it's fair to say you
know you you you owed them bit more
diligence to this problem and that you
can't claim ignorance when that you
essentially engaged in willful
blindness it sounds to me like it's
effectively the difference
between a silent partner who invested
but isn't really involved but you but
you at at the Dr have determined okay
this person isn't really a silent
partner member this is actually someone
who's been involved with decisionmaking
or managerial capacity than they are
liable
yes thank you representative fellows yes
why don't we consider having the The
Entity that has needs to pay room and
meals tax um give you give
Dr um some a form that says who the
specific name of the person that is
going to be responsible for the payment
of the this tax and then there would be
some kind of and tell them that they
have to um update it whenever that
changes and maybe make a penalty if they
don't keep you
know maybe no penalty but I don't want
them to get get away with like putting a
name on there and the person's like long
gone and it still sits there maybe make
it updated
frequently we actually do that um the
the the license application form
requires them to list who their you know
officers and who's managing that kind of
information
um when we're looking down the list at
members that perhaps we didn't know
about
it's usually because the people at the
top of the list are gone or are bankrupt
or otherwise insolvent and don't have
the money to pay so we we kind of start
with what's on our application for who's
who's who's a who's who's really running
this business and then we find oh yeah
that's the brilliant Chef he's dead so
now let's go see who else there is and
and that's the kind of the the analysis
we do because you know we don't like to
work harder than we have to you know we
want to work smarter not harder and so
you know we start with the more obvious
um and logical targets and when those
are when we're unsuccessful there then
we move down the
list thank you I'm going to end the work
585 okay I'm going to open the work
546 removing the requirement that an ex
conveyed is that right oh removing I'm
sorry removing the executory interest
okay um com
thoroughly we covered it thoroughly and
um okay representative spillsbury
thank you Mr chair um I happen to be uh
another one of el Chip's fan fans uh
there are two projects in recent years
in my hometown Charleston town that have
uh been done with elep funds restoration
of our town hall and of our library both
historic 19th century structures and I'm
convinced it would not have occurred
without their assistance uh having said
that that's a a plug um I think that
this is uh an absolutely simple
straightforward bill it's clear that
they don't need the executory interest
uh to pass uh to the state the state and
the AG have opined that there's an
adequate set of Protections in the trust
relationship and I don't think the bill
uh really raises any kinds of questions
I'm all for
it okay thank you let me um let me just
kind of ask the committee a question um
I I had raised a question on line five
um where the word acquire was crossed
out and um change to provide uh funding
for the acquisition um so how do people
feel like about that represent me I just
wanted to make a comment I was in on the
beginning of LP okay and on uh some of
the private discussions Before the bill
went in and um it makes perfect sense
that at first um they were thinking
about the program requiring the the uh
properties themselves but they soon in
in uh trying to use this model realized
it was going to take a great deal of uh
administrative capacity from in elip
that that was going to be
increasingly uh making it impossible for
them to do much except uh administer
pass grants and uh there was an LP
before that 20 30 years before that on
which um I think may have run into that
problem because it was originally fed
federally
funded and um so they changed that but
as she said they forgot to change this
sentence um so that what is happening
now which My Town also has profited from
twice I think uh
except that you have to be sure that El
Chip is going to be able to give you the
money and they frequently can't and so
you've made an agreement with somebody
and you have to pay the whole thing and
we've run into that a few times but on I
think that that part of it makes perfect
sense okay the whole thing makes perfect
sense all right thank you represented
fellows um yes so I originally had some
concerns
about you know decades down the line the
use of uh property that that was part of
this program turned into something it
wasn't supposed to be but I I'm guessing
now that if you look at
lines 16 through
that you know maybe maybe one of the
lawyers could explain it to me but I'm
hoping that that part would allow the
state to have
information and keep information about
what the property is supposed to be used
for and will somehow I'm not sure how
they find out when it's been sold but
but somehow know if there are proposed
if things are about to happen that
shouldn't
happen
so representative spills it just happens
that I'm preparing to acquire a piece of
land that is in fact subject to a coner
a easement and it's all recorded uh it's
a legal document it's just as enforcable
as if the uh Power Company had obtained
an easement to put power lines down the
edge of your property um so I think no
you can rest
easy representative Ames yeah I think
that bill is a a good bill it's a a
simple cleanup uh clarification and uh
we should just go ahead with it all
right it's essentially what everybody's
been saying thank you I'm going to close
now I get the next obviously the next
step here we have is the um executive
session
but um we probably should uh
Break um momentarily although I I'm
sensing kind of agreement on all five of
these but I might be wrong I don't uh
a let me just take a take a break for a
things
e
for those of you wondering we are going
to start an exec session uh in the next
couple
minutes
yeah yeah you have just figure out who's
who we that's the old we really need an
okay so who who's representan sitting in
cour
that
um only only when he calls the role just
confused so I've got the I've got the
Republican
that's good I think well
that it seems like he left I don't know
what happened to
him something must have happened he had
excuse me Mr chair Mr
chairman yes me uh for this for the
record I do have I am a member of the
board board of directors of elip but uh
since I'm here as a substitute uh my
vote belongs
to representative duet you can follow
his his lead so that's not a problem
thank
you as we'd expect from all the all the
subs to follow the lead of the vice
chair
here or the
ranking yeah or the ranking me or the
ranking member representative Al
representative Al is the ranking member
of
the
okay
uh Mr
chair yeah and uh for the record once
again uh I wanted to State the fact that
I am an executive director of a charity
that receives charitable gambling monies
okay um I personally do not receive any
monies but my uh nonprofit does okay
Mr chair I should also uh state that uh
I am on the board of directors and
former Treasurer liance San hearing
Foundation of New Hampshire Inc which
has received charitable charitable
gaming
okay let's get started um I'm going to
s472 and recognize representative duet
for a motion thank you Mr chairman I
move ought to pass on S SP 472 FN do I
have a second second by representative
Aly would you like to speak to your
motion for all reason discussed during
testimony and work session I hope we'll
all support the UT to pass
motion thank you any further
comment seeing none the clerk will call
the
role represent rep representative duet
yes representative spills excuse me
representative erery yes representative
Kenny representative spillsbury yes
representative PL votes yes
representative Rulo yes repres uh uh
represent or stepped out representative
roord
yes representative
uh
wette
yes representative Aly yes represent of
Ames yes represent of Southworth yes
represent of Malloy yes represent of
shamber yes represented fellows yes
represent Bolton yes represent elberger
yes representative Cahill yes
representative
Smith excuse me Horgan I'm represent
Oregon filling in re Smith so I also
vote Yes yes I I had it written down I
just screwed up I've done that before
which is not the first time uh and the
chair yes the the vote is uh 19 to zero
one not
voting okay the vote being 19 to zero
we'll without objection we'll put this
and I'll close the exact session on SB
472 we'll now open the exact session on
S sp432 and recognize representative
ducet thank you Mr chairman I move itl
second
yes representative PL seconds
it would you like to speak to your
motion
again hearing the testimony we heard I
believe there's uh much room to be
discussed and be wrong to pass this
legislation at this
time Mr chairman any com yes represent I
will be voting against this
itl um the par pool that representative
ducet sent to us the
definitions uh do not explicitly state
uh that ADW is covered for beding out
ofate it's mostly the parool is
for conduct within the state for horse
racing for Greyhounds for you put your
money in then it and I that's why I feel
that this
is these are for licenses held in the
state at the
location and I uh I feel that I will
have to uh uh vote no on this and uh I
will not allow
for to go to consent on the time
comes okay representative duet yeah and
I will be supporting the itl in that uh
the argument was made under the
interstate horse racing act which states
clearly in that piece of federal
legislation that it has to comply with
the laws of the state where the bet is
being being made and the state in which
the BET originates we have laws that
dictate that and I believe those laws
are not being
addressed as far as the rule that spells
out exactly what our laws are in New
Hampshire they're not complying with
those rules right now and those laws in
my
estimation representative fellows um yes
I would just like to say that I support
the itl because was the part about the
um what is it called
charity charitable thirdparty Financial
intermediary intermediary program um is
not
feasible uh it makes it look like there
would be some money available to go to
municipalities but we're it's pretty
clear that
$20,000 a year will will not be enough
for this to operate and that the fact
that current Charities
receiving uh money for charitable G
gambling will take priority over the
town's getting any money and they they
municipalities are not going to get
anything of any
significance represent
Aly thank you on I also am not going to
support the itl but um primarily because
I think that there are a lot of
different pieces of law that we have not
really been able to see yet uh
representative set told me that um the
one that he sent us is not the one he
should have sent us and it maybe it's
has to be somewhere else in the statute
on
and and the question of uh
of what happens when the notwithstanding
Clause is put in for me is is an
opposite problem than it one is for some
of my colleagues I don't think that
we're at the stage yet where we should
be voting on it but um uh I don't want
anyone else on the Democratic side to
follow my lead whichever you make up
your own
Ames yeah I I will be uh on the itl side
of this
um and I think it uh it's basically a
judgment that this uh has a number of
incomplete pieces that I I wouldn't I'm
not ready to support at this time and I
don't think they're necessary to go
thank you all right seeing no more uh
questions here or statements um I'll ask
the clerk to call the role this is an
itl motion for uh Senate Bill 432 FN
representative duet yes representative
uh
erery yes representative Kenny yes
representative spillsbury yes
representative PL votes yes
representative Rulo yes uh repres
stepped out representative Ros yes
represent
uh Willette
yes representative
yes representative Southworth yes
represent of Malloy
no represent of shamberg
no representative fellow yes
representative Bolton no
representative elberger
yes representative uh
Cahill
no representative Oregon um
no the
share
yes y 13- six one not voting this is the
final
count okay well representative shamber
got his wish won't be on consent thank
you Mr chairman and who is the minority
author uh minority we sh I'll write and
then I'll send it over to you okay pres
of
shamberg okay we'll close the uh exec
432 I now open the exec session on SB
597 do I have someone like like to make
a
motion yes represent elberger I move off
to pass do I have a second second by
representative
ducet uh would you like to speak to your
motion Representative elberger no I I I
think we all pretty much spoke out okay
um seeing no more comments the clerk
will call the role when he's ready on sp
sp 597
the role is ought to pass in 597
representative du
set yes representative uh erery yes
representative uh Kenny yes
representative spillsbury yes
representative PL votes yes
representative Rulo yes represent or
stepped out representative rord yes
representative
uh wette
yes representative Aly yes
representative Ames yes representative
Southworth yes representative Malloy yes
representative shamberg yes uh
representative fellows
no representative Bolton yes
representative elberger
yes representative Cahill yes
yes okay okay the vote title votes 18 to
one one not voting do you have an
objection to consent representative
consent and I'll close the exec session
on SP
597 uh s SP 585 um we're going to hold
that off uh till our
next meeting and um I would ask that uh
representative Ames and representative
SPS work on uh any potential language
they think might clarify if any uh and
anyone else who is passionate certainly
uh uh represent Elber will do the report
on 597
correct
okay yesterday
um today being Tuesday uh as soon as po
the the current the speakers asked that
we do these as soon as possible um if
you can get it to me by tomorrow morning
possible I mean by tomorrow morning I
noon um yeah anyone doing reports if you
can get them to me by 12: noon tomorrow
the speakers asked that we try to get
these done as quickly after exac as
possible um put your microphone on
please are we going to do 546 yes oh
that's
next okay I just wanted to say that 585
we're not going to exec today and what
what I'm planning I don't know the exact
date yet but the next time we meet um
which will not be next week um I also
going to check with Dr to see if when we
do this because this is this is it for
our bill and I don't want to come in
just for just for that one if we can
also get an update uh from Dr as to the
revenue uh
projections um so we will exec sp sp 585
and do Revenue projections whatever that
day is it'll it could be two weeks from
today I just have to make sure that Dr
would be ready for Revenue
projections discuss that I think they
they may be ready by the 14th but you
need to ask them yeah if they're not
ready in two weeks um our our cut off
here is may we have to exec everything
by May 16th um and I'm trying to avoid
having everyone come in just to exec one
bill um but if I can't piggyback Dr at
the same time we may have to come in uh
and exec that one bill Mr chair what are
the odds of us getting second committee
bills
uh I don't know low I would say low
yeah I mean there's always a chance we'
get a second committee Bill and have to
uh but
time I do have a dam bill which is it
coming to ways and means it may uh it is
a second committee bill doesn't it
doesn't say I've been it up until which
committee is going to but I know the
last one went to you I'm trying to think
I I did go to a meeting where there were
only three or four committees that had
second committee bills coming and Ways
and Means wasn't one of them but things
could always change but currently
currently there's no plan for a second
okay they haven't done that represent PL
I'm hoping that your committee will
strip out the financing part of it so it
doesn't come to Ways and
Means
well that's a yes we are definitely
considering that thank you okay so so
that's the status on 585 we'll hold off
and um next time we meet we'll exec that
one okay so representative Aly aren't we
doing 546 yeah I'm GNA do that now but I
just wanted to I'm just kind of going in
order I want people to know what's
happening with 585 okay so now open the
546 um would someone like to make a
motion on that representative spilsbury
thank you Mr chair I move OTP on SB
elme and would you like to speak to your
motion representative spillsbury yes I
think the bill proved non-controversial
and uh it's mostly in the nature of a
housekeeping Bill to reconcile the
language in the statute to the
Convention of providing funding for
acquisition rather than directly
acquiring and uh also for the fact that
uh the state and the AG have determined
that the executory interest is not a
important element in protecting the
interest of the state and that the trust
uh relationship does that adequately so
easy bill for us to
pass any further
comments seeing none the clerk will call
the role this is OTP on SB
546 uh representative duet yes
representative erery yes representative
Kenny yes representative spillsbury yes
representative PL votes yes
representative Rulo yes representative
yes representative Aly excuse me hold on
representative wette yes representative
Aly
yes representative Ames yes
representative Southworth yes
representative Malloy yes representative
shamber yes representative fellow yes
representative Bolton yes representative
elberger yes representative kale yes
representative Horgan yes and the chair
yes a vote is 190 one not
voting okay any objection to consent
okay and I'll close the exact session on
546 all right um very good we um made it
through that nicely um so again we just
have one bill left assuming we don't get
any second committee bills we are down
to one bill to exact s SP 585 and uh as
I said we will not meet next week so and
I'll try to find out as as soon as
possible what dr's situation is so that
we will either meet two weeks from today
or possibly three weeks from today but
we'll be very close to our deadline of
May 16th of getting this out the only
caveat there would be if suddenly we do
get a second committee Bill uh but um
but we are not meeting next week so
breaks my heart any any questions
um possibly I need I want to I as I said
I don't want to come back just to exec
one bill I want to get Dr updates as
well so if Dr says we're not ready then
I'm it'll be after that but I hope to
find out in the next couple
days what's
that no no we at a minimum we're not
meeting until two weeks from today which